GOOD MORNING.
WELCOME TO THIS HEARING OF THE.
JOINT COMMITTEE ON RULES OF THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE ASSEMBLY.
OF THE PERSON DAY'S HEARING IS
TO RECEIVE A REPORT.
APPARENT FOR US CONCERNING THE
STATE CAPITOL AND EX UP PROJECT.
AND.
.
I WILL OPEN AND THEN PASS THE
OPENING TO MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR
ANTHONY CANNELLA THE.
VICE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE.
AND THEN WE'LL HEAR REPORT FROM
ARCHITECTURAL FIRM.
.
AS WE START THIS HEARING AYE AYE
DIFFERENT WANT TO.
BEGIN AT THE BEGINNING THAT
KNOWLEDGE AND THANK THE
LEADERSHIP OF GOVERNOR BROWN.
WHO WITH HIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
SENIOR PERSONNEL AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN?
INITIATED A CONVERSATION OR WHAT
TO DO WITH THIS ANNEX.
ARM ITS A PECULIARITY OF MY
CAREER THAT AND.
TWO MONTHS BEFORE I WAS MARRIED
IN JULY OF NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED.
A BILL BY FORMER SENATOR WILL
SURELY ON RALPH.
AB TOOL SEVEN.
MOVING THE FUNDS FOR THE WEST
WING PROJECT INTO LET'S HAVE
ACCOUNTS
SELECT YOUR TRIGGER PROCEED.
AND OF COURSE TO THIS DAY THE
WEST WING IS A BEAUTIFUL
STRUCTURE.
WE SEE PEOPLE WALKING THROUGH
IT.
WALKING UP TOWARDS HER TO GAZE
AT THIS SYMBOL OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
AND ENJOYING IT DURING THEIR
VISITS ON A DAILY BASIS.
AND SO WE COME NOW AT DURING THE
GOVERNOR'S SECOND TENURE. WITH
THE PROSPECT THAT HE MIGHT BE
SIGNED IN THE FUNDING BILL THAT
WOULD PROVIDE FUNDING. FOR THE
SECOND HALF OF THE STATE CAPITOL
FACILITY. A CONVERSATION WHICH
HE HIMSELF INITIATED WHAT THE
SUPPORT OF HIS SENIOR TAME.
MARRIED BARBELL BADGER SECTOR
GOVERN OPERATIONS.
JULIE A DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS
IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
MISTER DANIEL KIM DIRECTOR
GENERAL SERVICES MARIBEL AND
DANIEL CAME IN THEIR SENIOR
STAFF MET. OUR STAFF OVER IN THE
XEROX BUILDING A IN THE SPRING
OF LAST YEAR TO HAVE A LONG
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHERE WE
NEEDED TO GO. WHAT TYPES OF
STUDIES WOULD BE APPROPRIATE AND
THE STUDY WILL HEAR ABOUT TODAY
IS AN OUTGROWTH OF THAT
CONVERSATION? WITH THE GOVERNOR
SENIOR STAFF
ALSO JASON KENNEDY WHO'S THE
DIRECTOR VICE.
A DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE REAL
ESTATE SERVICES DIVISION TGS
ACTUALLY IS ACCOMPANIED US ON
TRIPS AROUND THE COUNTRY TO LOOK
AT SOME STATE CAPITALS.
BECAUSE MANY STATES
OUR SIR BUT AHEAD OF US ON THIS
CURVE OF LOOKING AT OLD.
DAVID LET'S SAY FOR SALAS AND
UPDATED.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF PATHFINDER'S
ON THIS CONVERSATION
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE LEARN FROM
THAT WAS ACTUAR FIRST HEARING
LASTSUMMER HEARING FROM SOME IS
BEEN THE MIDDLE OF THOSE.
PROJECTS
AW I'M GLAD TO SEE OUR STATE
ARCHITECT CHECK WIDE OF HERE
TODAY HE'S BEEN VERY GRACIOUS TO
ME. A IN CONVERSATION PROVIDE IN
SUPPORT.
AND.
DOWN THE FINANCIAL SIDE WE'VE
HAD ACTOR INVOLVED FOR KEELY
BOSS WITH THE CABINET SECRETARY
FOR GOVERNOR BROWN. AND OF
COURSE MICHAEL COHEN A DIRECTOR
OF FINANCE
WHO.
WAS I BEEN HIS OFFICE MANY A
TIME HE'S BEEN IN MY OFFICE
HOPING I'LL HELPING ME AND OUR
TEAM JUST THINK THROUGH WHAT WE
ARE DOING.
.
SO.
I THINK THIS PROJECT REPRESENTS
AN OPTION FOR US TO DO THREE
VERY IMPORTANT THING FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
ONE IS IMPROVING ACCESS TO THE
BUILDING.
AND.
.
WE KNOW THAT THE BUILDING THE
ANNEX WAS BUILT IN FIFTY TWO IT
DOES NOT HAVE.
SPRINKLERS.
BUT ALSO DID THE.
EIGHTY A ACCESS IS NOT THERE WE
WALK AROUND THE BUILDING THOSE
OF US WALK PAST THESE LIFTS ALL
THE TIME. NOT REALIZING HELP
CONTENT KRISTEN GOOD BE HOW
BULKY THEY COULD BE. HOW SOMEONE
HAS A A MOTORIZED CHAIR WITH
ROOM FOR THEIR CRUTCHES IN THE
BACK? THAT THAT THAT MAY
ACTUALLY NOT FIT THE LIVES WE
PROVIDE.
SO THERE'S MANY WAYS IN WHICH
THE BUILDING IS NOT WELCOME AND
ALL CALIFORNIANS THE SHEEN ON
THE FLOOR DOES NOT ADDRESS
PEOPLE VISUAL OCULAR
IMPAIRMENTS.
AND EVEN THE THE HARD SERVICES
THE QUARTERS AFFECTED NOISE
LEVEL THE CAN AFFECT PEOPLE WITH
HEARING ISSUE SO THERE'S. MANY
WAYS WE MIGHT IMPROVE IT.
AND THIS ACTUALLY WOULD BE IN
KEEPING WITH THE ORIGINAL INTENT
OF CALIFORNIANS.
I.
I GREATLY ENJOY THE FACT WHEN
YOU'RE ON THE WEST WING AND YOU
WALK UP AND DOWN THOSE
STAIRCASES.
DECORATING THE BOTTOMS OF ALL
THE NEWEL POST CARVED IN THE
WATER PINEAPPLES.
WHICH OUR SYMBOL OF HOSPITALITY
BECAUSE THE EIGHTEEN SIXTIES YOU
HAD TO COME TO.
THE CUT MILIEU ES FROM HAWAII.
AND IT'S
IT CAUSES ME REFLECTED. WHEN THE
BUILDING OPENED IN THE WEST
WING.
EVERYBODY WHO WENT ANYWHERE IN
THE BUILDING USING THOSE
STAIRCASES EVERYWHERE THEY TURN
THEIR SUPPLYING UPPER REMIND
THEM. OF THE WELCOMING MESSAGE
OF THE. PEOPLE'S HOUSE.
IT IS A MARVEL TO ME THAT THE
WEST WING WITH SO MANY GREAT
SYMBOLS CONCERNING OUR DEMOCRACY
AND WELCOMING PEOPLE.
SO RICH WAS SYMBOLISM THAT WE
COME IN THE ANNEX AND THE
SYMBOLS ARE NOT HERE.
SOMEHOW THERE IS A TOTAL FAIL TO
CARRY FOR THIS VISION OF
HOSPITALITY AND THE USE OF
SYMBOLS TO CONVEY THE MEANING OF
OUR SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT.
WHEN YOU GIVE THE ADDICTS ARE
JUST NOT THERE.
ARE. ALSO WILL JUST THE IDEA OF
SUPPORTING GREATER CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT
I THINK.
.
WHEN I FIRST STARTED THE
BUILDING IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN WHAT THE KIDS HAD TO SEE
WAS ACCOUNTING EXHIBITS.
THEN MY FIRST BOSS IN CHARGE OF
THE WEST WING ADDED THE MUSEUM
ROSE WHICH WAS A GREAT LEAP
FORWARD.
AND NOW YOU GO TO THE GETTY
MUSEUM LOS ANGELES HIM OF
NATURAL HISTORY OUR OWN GOLDEN
STATE MUSEUM.
THE TECHNOLOGY OF INTERACTIVE
EXHIBITS IS SO MUCH GREATER.
AND SO I THINK A BUILDING
PROJECTS ALLOWS US TO WEAVE INTO
IT. A GREATER EXPERIENCE FOR
THOSE WHO WOULD COME TO LEARN
WHAT OUR DEMOCRACY IS ABOUT AND
PARTICIPATE.
.
AND THIS SUPPORTS OUR CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT GENERALLY.
SO.
.
TO CONCLUDE I JUST WANT TO KNOW.
HOW WE GOT HERE WAS THAT I AND I
THINK A SUPPORT FOR TRANSPARENCY
PURPOSES?
IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY SIXTEEN.
SHORTLY AFTER I BECAME. RULES
CHAIR
WE PREPARED A REQUEST FOR
INFORMATION SEEKING
ARCHITECTURAL FIRMS WITH.
PEOPLE'S HOUSE EXPERIENCE.
TO SEE IF THERE BE WILLING TO
ASSIST US IN A STUDY OF THIS
BUILDING.
ARE WE HAD.
EVENTUALLY SEVEN FIRM SUBMIT.
WE WERE USED LEGISLATIVE STAFF
TO REDACT ALTHOUGH YOU
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION THOSE
VARIOUS PROPOSALS.
WE USED A MEMBER OF MY STAFF AND
MEMBERS SEND ASSEMBLY STAFF.
TO REVIEW THOSE PROPOSES USING A
SCORING MATRIX. PARA BY AN
OUTSIDE LAW FIRM THAT
SPECIALIZES IN CONSTRUCTION.
SO WE HAD A LAW FROM THE DESERT
SORT THINGS OUR BREAD AND
BUTTER.
LOOK AT THE ARE OFF I TELL US
HOW WE COULD SCORE THESE THINGS
CONSIST WITH THE ARAFAT I. TRAIN
THE PEOPLE DID IT WE'VE MADE OUR
STAFF SIGN NON CONFLICT
AGREEMENTS.
TO ESTABLISH THAT THAT WAS SORT
OF A SQUEAKY CLEAN PROCESS
WHEN THEY WERE DONE ALL WE KNEW
WAS THAT THEY HAD THE TOP THREE
THERE WAS NO RANKING PROVIDED.
THERE WERE NOT TELL US WHO THEY
THOUGHT WAS THE BEST
THEY JUST GIVES THE TOP THREE.
AND THEN THE OTHER DAY LAST YEAR
US SENATE CANNELLA AND I WOULD
MISS GRAVER AND MISTER ALVAREZ.
CONVENED PRESENTATIONS WERE THE
TOP FIRMS CAME REPRESENTED.
SO THE FIRMWARE HEARING FROM
TODAY IS THE FIRM THAT WENT
THROUGH THAT PROCESS AND ROSE TO
THE TOP.
AND SO YOU SEE THAT REFLECTED IN
THEIR WORK.
.
I DO WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE THAT
THERE IS AN ANNEX WEBSITE FOR
ANYONE WHO MIGHT LOOK HERE.
.
IT'S ANNEX DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA
DOT GOV.
ANNEX DOT ASSEMBLY GOT CA DOT
GOV AND THEN WE'RE GOING THAT
WEBSITE EVEN NOW THIS MORNING IS
HEARINGS UNDERWAY WILL FIND
LINKS TO EVERYTHING INCLUDING
THE REPORT.
WE'VE WE'VE KEPT THAT WEBSITE UP
THROUGHOUT THE PAST YEAR TO MAKE
EVERYWHERE DOING VERY
ACCESSIBLE.
.
AND.
OBVIOUSLY IT OTHER OBJECT OF
THIS.
IS AT THE OTHER DAY WE HAVE ALL
THOSE FOURTH GRADERS WHO COME
HERE THE PUBLIC OF COMES HERE.
PEOPLE BE UNFAMILIAR WITH THIS
BUILDING WE WANT THIS TO BE A
SAFE BUILDING TO VISIT.
SO PARENTS WHO WHO SEND THEIR
KIDS TO A DELIGHTFUL DAY IN THE
CAPITAL HAVE AN ASSURANCE THAT
THAT'S WHAT WILL UNFOLD. SO WITH
THAT I JUST THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE. AND I WOULD TURN OUT
TO MY CHAIR CENTER CANNELLA FOR
SOME REMARKS THANK YOU SIR
CANNELLA CHRISTIANITY.
APPRECIATE YOU WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE THE.
YOU MENTIONED THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE
AND A AND THIS IS THE PEOPLE'S
HOUSE I THINK WE'RE FORGET THAT
WE THINK OF THIS AS AN OFFICE
BUILDING THAT WE COME TO EVERY
DAY AND. AND ALL THE HONEST.
I GET CONFUSED NAVIGATING THIS
BUILDING OCCASIONALLY HAVE BEEN
HERE THIS MY EIGHT YEAR SO
I CAN IMAGINE BEING A FOURTH
GRADER IN A TIME OF EMERGENCY
TRYING TO FIGURE YOUR WAY OUT OF
HERE.
AND SINCE I'VE BEEN PARTS
PROCESS I HAVE STARTED LOOKING
UP AT THE CEILINGS LOOKING FOR
FIRE SPRINKLERS THAT I HAVE NOT
SEEN ONE YET.
SURE THERE ARE SPRINKLED
THROUGHOUT THE BUILDING BUT WHEN
WE HAVE A STANDARD FOR EVERY
OTHER BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA.
IT SAYS THEY HAVE TO MEET ANY OF
THESE
PACIFIC GUIDELINES ESPECIALLY
WITH.
TO A DRESS ARE A ACCOMMODATE A
PEOPLE DISABILITIES AND WE DON'T
DO IT IN FACT I WAS UP AT.
ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE ON
FOURTH FLOOR I THINK IN THE OLD
PART OF THE BUILDING.
AND.
I WAS THERE WAS A SCHEDULED A
WHEELCHAIR TRYING TO NAVIGATE
THE STAIRS AND LIFTED WORK.
AND THIS PERSON IS TRYING TO TO
DO THEIR JOB AND OR OR ADVOCATE
FOR WHATEVER THEY WANTED
ADVOCATE FOR AND THEY COULD NOT.
ACCESS THE ROOM BECAUSE THE
LIFTED WORK AND I THINK THAT'S A
THAT'S A REAL INDICTMENT ON US
IN.
HOW WE'VE KEPT THIS BUILDING UP
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS SO?
A I KNOW THERE ARE SOME THAT ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT A NEW BUILDING
AND THAT THE POTENTIAL COST FOR
A NEW BUILDING.
BUT AT WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THIS
BUILDINGS BEEN AROUND FOR SIXTY
YEARS THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
THAT COME TO THIS BUILDING EVERY
YEAR. I THINK WE OWE IT TO THEM
TO A PROVIDING ADDICTS THAT IS A
COMEDY INTO A TO ALL FOLKS.
IS SAFE FED HAS PARK SPRINKLERS
A
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A SPRINKLER
OCCASIONALLY.
SO I THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
PROCESS AND.
I I HAVE BEEN IMPRESSED.
LESS FOR WITH WITH THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE YOU BEEN CLUED
ME ON ON EVERYTHING. A SINCE I
BECAME A PART IS PROCESS AND
IT'S REALLY AN EXCITING PROCESS
AND REALLY. A VERY SELDOM DO
PEOPLE GET TO BE INVOLVED IN
SOMETHING THAT IS HISTORIC IN
NATURE AND IN THIS BUILDING A WE
DO RIGHT COULD BE AROUND FOR
ANOTHER SIXTY TWO HUNDRED YEARS
AND AND.
BELONG LE BEYOND OUR LIFETIMES
AND SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT SO
AGAIN I THANK YOU FOR INCLUDING
ME THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK SO
FAR AND AND.
LET'S GET STARTED.
SO ARE AS RETURN. I WILL POINT
OUT.
ONE OF THE S. IN THINGS ABOUT
AND THINK THE PROJECT RIGHT NOW
IS WE HAVE BEEN.
WE HAVE BEEN BUILDING A LOT OF
COURTHOUSES AROUND CALIFORNIA
IN THE IN THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS.
AND THAT ACTUALLY HAS A VERY
IMPORTANT BENCHMARK BECAUSE WE
KNOW COURTHOUSES.
HAVE A HIGH DEGREE OF SECURITY
THEY HAVE TO IN YOUR TECHNOLOGY.
THEY HAVE HIGHER THAN AVERAGE
FINISHES THEY NEED TO HAVE LARGE
SPACES TO ACCOMMODATE JURY PULLS
THE ACTUAL COURTROOM FOR SO
THEMSELVES SO REQUIRE. A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF ENGINEERING.
TO ACCOMMODATE THE TRAFFIC
VOLUMES IT MOVED THROUGH THE
COURTHOUSES.
SO ONE OF THE INTERESTING THINGS
FOR US IN THE LEGISLATURE IS AT
THIS MOMENT WE'RE CONCERNED WHAT
WE MIGHT DO WITH OUR AN EX.
WE HAVE AN AWFUL LOT OF DATA
CONCERNING VERY SIMILAR
BUILDINGS BEING BUILT ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA AND THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THEM.
SO ITS NOT WERE NOT QUITE FLYING
AS BLIND AS YOU MIGHT FEEL. A
EVEN THOUGH IT SAY IT IS A NEW
ISSUE FOR US IN THE LEGISLATURE.
THE SUCH A PUBLIC FACILITIES OF
THE SCALE ARE BEING BUILT ALL
OVER AND THAT BECOMES IMPORTANT
BENCHMARK SO WITH THAT.
.
THE FIRM THAT WE HAVE USED IS CS
EACH Q. WAY. INK.
THEY HAVE ALSO WEST SACRAMENTO
BOISE IDAHO.
THERE WITH THIS YEAR WE HAVE
WITH US.
JOHN MULLIN OF WHO IS EXECUTIVE
VICE PRESIDENT SINCE H. KUWAIT
ALSO MARK GARY DIRECTOR AND
SENIOR ARCHITECT WITH THE FIRM.
DANIEL WEAVER SENIOR ARCHITECT
WITH THEM AND STEVE WAKE WHEN
PRINCE FOR MANAGING ARCHITECT.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA FOR THEM.
SO MISTER MULLIN IF YOU WILL.
TAKE US THROUGH THE REPORT AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK.
WELL I'D LIKE TO START WITH
THANKING YOU ALL FOR ALLOWING US
TO COME AND.
DISCUSS THIS REPORT.
THERE'S A LOT OF PAGES AND I
THINK EVERYONE IS WORTH READING
SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS COME
WALKING THROUGH.
HOW THE BOOK WAS A FORMER AIDE
FORMATTED AND?
?
OUR PROCESS THAT WE WENT THROUGH
TO ACTUALLY DEVELOP THE REPORT
CELL. STARTING WITH I GUESS I'D
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT.
SEES ISSUE A SPECIFICALLY.
AND GIVE YOU KIND OF AND.
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT OUR
EXPERTISE ARE WHAT WE DO.
WITH US. WITHOUT I GUESS I'D
LIKE TO SAY THIS IS ISSUE IS
BEEN AROUND FOR A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE YEARS.
NONE OF THOSE GUYS ARE STILL
ALIVE.
.
SHE LOVES IT WHEN I DO JOKES.
OUR FIRST STARTED IN.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY NINE THE FIRST
AS A SOLE PROPRIETOR AND THEN AS
A PARTNERSHIP AND NOW AS A.
CORPORATION WE HAVE OFFICES IN
WEST SACK DENVER COLORADO.
AND IN BOISE IDAHO.
WHERE FIRM OF AROUND A HUNDRED
PEOPLE? AND ONE OF OUR EXPERTISE
IS THAT WE'VE BEEN FOCUSING ON
ARE THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE OR
CAPITOL BUILDINGS.
THE TEAM THAT WORKED ON THIS
PROJECT.
FOR THE STUDY HERE HAS WORKED
ON NOW THREE CAPITOL BUILDINGS.
WITHIN THE UNITED STATES AND
THE WESTERN.
SECTOR.
IN SOME CASES THE PROJECTS WERE
GROUND BEGINNING JUST TO WHERE
YOU GUYS ARE OUT RIGHT NOW THE
MASTER PLANNING PROGRAMMING.
ASPECT IN IN SOME CASES WE WERE
BROUGHT IN TO HELP RESCUE.
PROJECTS WERE HAVING A HARD TIME
CONTINUING.
IN THIS CASE HERE WERE ONCE
AGAIN INVOLVED AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE PROCESS WHICH I THINK IS
THE MOST. IMPORTANT PART BECAUSE
IT'S YOUR FIRST STEP FORWARD.
AS WE AS WE LOOK AT THIS WITH
THEIR PROJECTS WE'VE ACTUALLY
WORKED ON IN THE PAST WE HAVE A
FEW THINGS THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
OFFER FROM OUR EXPERIENCE THAT
WE THINK ARE. IN BE.
USEFUL.
THROUGH PROCESS BUT WHAT I CAN
SAY IS THAT THERE'S.
MANY MORE ASPECTS TO DESERT
DESIGNING AND DEVELOPING AN
EXPANSION TO A CAPITOL BUILDING
THEN. YOU MIGHT PARTICULARLY NO
AT THIS POINT AND TIME.
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS I WOULD
SUGGEST IN ONE OF THOSE FIRST
THINGS THAT I AM IS NOT
NECESSARILY ILLUSTRATED IN A
COST TO. FOR CONSTRUCTION BUDGET
IS
THE PUBLIC NOTIFICATION AND THE
PEOPLE THAT WORKED IN THE
BUILDING NOTIFICATION IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT AS YOU WORK ON THESE
PROJECTS THAT YOU CONSIDER.
YOUR INFORMATION.
PROCESSING PROGRAMS WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE COMING TO VISIT YOUR
CAPITOL BUILDING. DURING THE
CONSTRUCTION CYCLE AND DURING
THE DESIGN CYCLE BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO SEE IT FOR ONE LAST TIME
AS IT CURRENTLY RESIDES.
I'M YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE YOU
HAVE A VERY WELL RUN INFORMATION
PROGRAM BECAUSE THERE WILL BE
MORE PEOPLE THAN YOU EVER
THOUGHT INTERESTED IN THIS
PROJECT AS YOU MOVE FORWARD.
ONE OF THE NEXT THINGS I THINK
I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT IT WE
FIND IN EVERY CAPITOL BUILDING
WE'VE EVER. WORKED WITH OR BEEN
TO IS THAT NONE OF THEM HAVE
ENOUGH MEETING SPACE CONFERENCE
SPACE.
OR APPROPRIATE HEARING SPACES.
GENERALLY SPEAKING.
MOST PEOPLE HAVE DONE MUCH LIKE
YOU HAVE THEY'VE ADDED SOME INTO
THEIR.
CAPITOL COMPLEX SPECIFICALLY
AND THEN THEY'VE HAD TO DO SOME
REMOTING TO OF THAT. AND A LOT
OF THEM HAVE ACTUALLY RESORTED
TO THE USE OF ELECTRONICS FOR
ALMOST.
ALL THEIR INCLUSION OF THEIR A
GENERAL POPULATION. YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY IN THIS BUILDING TO.
TO ACTUALLY GRASP THE SUBJECT
AND MOVE IT FORWARD AND NOT
ALLOW FOR BETTER HEARING SPACE
BETTER MEETING SPACE.
THROUGHOUT THE BUILDING.
BUT BUILDINGS ARE SYMBOLS OF
THIS TYPE ARE SYMBOLS.
FOR THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE ENDS
FOR THE PEOPLE OF THE UNITED
STATES THAT THAT.
THE DRAW PEOPLE TOGETHER AND
THERE THEY ARE THE SYMBOL OF
THE.
GOVERNMENT FOR THE PEOPLE BY
THE PEOPLE.
AS WE WORK ON THESE PROJECTS WE
HAVE TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT WHAT
THAT ACTUALLY MEANS.
AS WE'RE DEVELOPING.
DESIGNS AND THOSE WERE
DEVELOPING WHY PEOPLE NEED TO
BILL AND THE BUILDING AND HOW
THE PEOPLE NEED TO WORK WITHIN
THE BUILDING.
MOST OF THE TIME WE FIND IS THAT
THERE'S CONFLICTS IN SPACE USE.
WE'VE TYPICALLY FOUND THAT
THERE'S NEVER ENOUGH SPACE FOR
ALL THE FUNCTIONAL NEEDS WITHIN
A BUILDING IN THIS BUILDING WAS
BUILT.
SIXTY FIVE YEARS AGO FOR A PART
TIME LEGISLATURE.
IT DOES NOT CURRENTLY HOUSE WHAT
FROM OUR VARIOUS CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE USERS WITHIN THE
BUILDING HOUSE ALL THE.
.
CAPABILITY THAT.
IS A DESIRED WITHIN THE
BUILDING.
ONE THING OF OF NOTE AND I THIS
IS PROBABLY SOMETHING YOU'LL
HEAR A LOT ABOUT OVER TIME IS
THAT THE BUILDING ITSELF.
AS EXTRACTED PREDATES.
ALL THE MODERN.
BUILDING CODES HEALTH SAFETY
CODES.
ACCESSIBILITY COATS.
AND.
.
I CARRY NEEDS OF THE OF THIS
PERIOD OF TIME.
ALL THE BUILDINGS WE GOING TO
TYPICALLY HAVE.
AGING MECHANICAL AGING
ELECTRICAL.
AND EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM.
AS RETROFITTED TECHNOLOGY NONE
OF THESE BUILDINGS WERE BUILT
WITH THE IDEA THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE THIS KIND OF TECHNOLOGY
THINK BACK FIFTY YEARS AGO.
THERE WEREN'T CELLPHONES THEY
WERE IN PREVALENT USE.
LAPTOPS WERE AVAILABLE FOR
PEOPLE. THERE WERE DESKTOPS AND
IF YOU DID HAVE THE ADVANTAGE OF
HAVING SOME SORT OF LOVABLE
COMPUTER YOU COULD CARRY AROUND
A COMPUTER AT A FOUR INCH
SCREEN.
TODAY THEY'RE UBIQUITOUS EVERY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SO THOSE NEED
TO BE THOUGHT OUT WHAT WE NEED
TO THINK ABOUT IS WHAT IS GOING
TO BE LIKE IN FIFTY YEARS AND
MAKE SURE THAT THEY
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN SUPPORT THAT
IN THE FUTURE BECAUSE NOW WE
HAVEA BETTER EYE. ON WHERE GOV
OUR COUNTRY IS GOING AND AREN'T
OUR WORLD IS GOING.
OF CURRENT TODAY.
IS EVERYBODY IS KEENLY AWARE OF
THE SECURITY SECURITY IN THESE
KIND OF BUILDINGS AS I SAID
THEY'RE BEACONS.
MAKING SURE YOU MAINTAIN
SECURITY OF ALL THE VISITORS MAY
TO MAINTAIN SECURITY OF ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT WORK IN THE BUILDING
AND SECURITY TAKES ON MANY
DIFFERENT FACES.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
BUILDING TAKES INTO
CONSIDERATION HOW DO YOU HANDLE
A BUSLOAD OF VISITORS.
AND HOW DO YOU HANDLE THAN A
POTENTIAL FIRE WITHIN THE
BUILDING AND HOW DOES EVERYBODY
GET OUT OF BUILDING THAT'S PART
OF SECURITY CONCERNS AT THIS
BUILDING.
IS ACTUALLY LIMITED AT THIS
POINT TIME AND. MARK HERE IN A
MINUTE HERE WILL TALK.
THROUGH SOME OF THE BUILDING
DEFICIENCIES THAT WERE.
ILLUSTRATING WITHIN OUR BLOCK.
BUILDINGS OF THIS TYPE
TYPICALLY HOUSE
SEPARATE TENANTS WITH SIMILAR
GOALS YOU END UP WITH.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE YOU END UP
WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN MANY
CASES JOINED UP WITH ELECTED
OFFICIAL OFFICES ALL IN THE SAME
BUILDING.
THEY ALL HAVE DIFFERENT FOR
DIFFERENT BUT SIMILAR PURPOSES
THAT THEY'RE WORKING TOWARDS AND
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE MAINTAIN
THOSE KIND OF ASPECTS OF. HOW
THE GOVERNMENT'S SUPPOSED TO
WORK WE NEED TO DEAL WITH WHAT
THE CONSTITUTIONAL? OUR
REQUIREMENTS ARE FACILITATE THE
ACCESS TO CONSTITUENTS.
MAINTAIN THE GOVERNMENT FOR THE
PEOPLE BY THE PEOPLE. ALL
WORKING IN THE BUILDING AND ON
THE BUILDING DURING THE
CONSTRUCTION PROCESS.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE. IN THIS IS
ONE OF MY.
.
CABBIE OUTSIDE ALL OF THIS
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE ELECTED
TO MAKE A DECISION ABOUT THIS.
GATHERING IN BRINGING TOGETHER
EVERYBODY WITH A SIMILAR IN
COMMON VISION TO BE ABLE TO
PROCEED AHEAD IS PARAMOUNT TO
MAKE THE PROCESS MOVE SMOOTHLY.
.
WHEN WE STARTED THIS PROJECT
RESTARTED IT WITH ESSENTIALLY
FIVE OPTIONS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT IN NO PARTICULAR BIAS TO ANY
ONE OF THESE AS WE STARTED BUT
WE WANTED TO START AND THE
CONSERVATIVE NATURE.
WE START WITH THE IDEA THAT
MAYBE ALL WE REALLY HAVE TO DO
IS FIX IT UP.
CAN KEEP THE BUILDING AS IT IS
WE CAN.
AND IN.
MOST ARCHITECTS WORTH THEIR SALT
CAN SOLVE MOST OF THE.
ACCESSIBILITY ISSUES.
BUT THERE'S A LOT THAT HAS TO BE
DONE IN THIS BUILDING AND
THERE'S A LOT OF NEED TO EXPRESS
DURING OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE. USERS OF THE BUILDING THAT
WE CANNOT OVERCOME JUST BY
FIXING IT UP AS IT IS.
OUR WE LOOKED AT REMODELING THE
BUILDING.
WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY AS INVASIVE
AS.
PRETTY MUCH THE REST OF WHAT
I'LL BE TALKING ABOUT HERE
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO MOVE PEOPLE
OUT OF THE BUILDING TO REMODEL
MECHANICAL ELECTRICAL SYSTEMS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO BE
MAINTAINED.
FOR PARTS OF THE BUILDING AND
MOST THESE BUILDINGS WERE NOT
ACTUALLY DESIGNED WITH THE IDEA
THAT YOU CAN SHUT OFF THIS
OFFICE IN TURN THIS OFFICE ON
HERE. SO.
GENERALLY SPEAKING UP TO
RELOCATE OUT OF THE BUILDING TO
BE ABLE TO DO A FULL REMODEL.
IT WOULD NOT ACTUALLY.
GIVE YOU ALL THE BENEFITS
IN THE REMODEL ANY MUCH MORE
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT YOU WOULD
GET.
IN.
SIMPLY CHANGING THE PROBLEMS
THAT YOU CURRENTLY NO THERE
WITHIN THE BUILDING.
THIRDLY AS WE LOOKED AT IT WE
SAID THEN ONE OF THE BETTER
OPTIONS MIGHT BE ADDING ON TO
THE BUILDING SO WE STARTED OUT
WITH THE IDEA. THAT WHAT IF WE
JUST REMODELED THE PARTS WE HAD
IN AND OUT ADD ON TO THE
BUILDING WE COULD WE ACTUALLY
SATISFY THE NEEDS. THEIR
EXPRESSED TO US OR VARIOUS
MEETINGS.
AS IT CAME TO BE WE FOUND THAT
IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT WORKING
WITHIN THE EXISTING STRUCTURAL
GREG WITHIN THE BUILDING. AND
THE FLOOR TO CEILING HEIGHTS
WITHIN THE BUILDING
TO BE ABLE TO FACILITATE BEING
ABLE TO APPLY ALL THE DESIRES
AND NEEDS THAT WERE EXPRESSED TO
US DURING OUR CONVERSATION.
ULTIMATELY WE CAME TO.
AND THE WITHIN THE ACTUAL BILL
THAT.
PUT THIS FORWARD IT WAS ABOUT
REMOVING AND REPLACING THE
BUILDING OR.
REMODELING THE BUILDING AND SO
WE ACTUALLY EXPANDED UPON THAT
AS WE WENT THROUGH TO SAY WHAT
OTHER OPTIONS YOU MAY HELP
AVAILABLE.
ULTIMATELY FALL UPON THEY REMOVE
AND REPLACE OPTION WITHIN THE.
.
REPLACES BUILDING WITHIN.
THE EXISTING LOCATION.
AND THEN WE ALSO LOOKED AT THE
OPTION OF
BUILDING A NEW BUILDING OUR NEW
BUILDINGS AS SOME PEOPLE MAY
HAVE SEEN.
ALREADY PUBLISHED IT AND DURING
POINT TIME IN A DIFFERENT
LOCATION.
THROUGH OUR REPORT HERE AS WE
TALK HOPEFULLY WE'LL SEE IS WHY
WE CAME TO THEIR CONCLUSIONS
THAT WE CAME TO.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE ROOM
MOVING REPLACE WAS THE ONE THAT.
WAS THEM MOST EASY TO SATISFY
ALL THE DESIRES OF THE.
CODE ISSUES ALL THE SAFETY
ISSUES.
AND.
.
ALL OF THE NEEDS FOR THE
ADDITIONAL SQUARE FOOTAGE WITHIN
THE BUILDINGS WOULD BE CAN.
.
MORE CONSISTENTLY DONE AND
RESOLVE SOME OF THE WAY FUNDING
ISSUES THAT WE ACTUALLY KNOW OF.
BUILDING IN A DIFFERENT LOCATION
WAS CONSIDERED STRONGLY VOTE
WAS.
.
RESOUND ONLY RESENT.
I'D TAKEN OFF THE LIST BECAUSE
OF PEOPLE DID NOT LIKE THE IDEA
OF BEING SEPARATED FROM THE
CHAMBERS.
AND SEPARATED FROM THEIR
CONSTITUENTS AND HAVING TO WALK
ACROSS STE.
AN AREA OF SURFACE
TO BE ABLE TO GET BACK AND FORTH
IN A TIMELY FASHION TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE SURE THAT HEARINGS AND
EVERYTHING STARTED ON TIME.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO START WITH ON
OUR NEXT SLIDE HERE IS?
?
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE QUOTES
THAT WERE PROVIDED.
PART OF THE WAY THROUGH THE
PROCESS YOU'LL FIND IT WITHIN
THE BOOK.
AND YOU ALSO FIND IN ON THE BACK
COVER THE BOOK IT WAS PROVIDED
TO US BY ASSEMBLYMAN COOLEY
WHICH WE ACTUALLY THOUGHT WAS.
VERY APROPOS FOR ACTUALLY MOST
OF THE WORK THAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING AND I'LL JUST READ IT TO
YOU QUICKLY.
THE CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA'S NEW
CAPITAL ANNEX SHOULD CONVEY THAT
TO THE VISITORS.
CALIFORNIA'S POSITIVE AND
HOPEFUL HOLE FILLED OUTLOOK.
FOUNDED UPON A DELIBERATIVE
DEMOCRACY WHICH UNFOLDS THERE.
BY WELCOMING ALL CALIFORNIANS
ENGAGING ALL CALIFORNIANS
SAFEGUARDING THE FUTURE OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
AND DEMONSTRATING A HEALTHFUL.
ACCESSIBLE AND SUSTAINABLE
DESIGN.
LET ME STOP THERE REAL QUICK SO
WHERE ESSENTIALLY WHAT THAT IS
SAYING IS THAT THE BUILDING
SHOULD BE ENGAGING TO EVERYONE.
AND BY DEMONSTRATING
BEING EXAMPLE FOR YOUR STATE.
OF THE KIND OF ARCHITECTURE AND
CONSTRUCTION YOU WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE.
WHILE PRESERVING THE BEAUTY AND
VISTAS.
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGACY CAPITOL
PARK.
AND INVITING ALL GUESTS ALL OF
ITS GUESTS.
TO EXPLORE AND TAKE PRIDE IN ONE
OF THE MOST ENERGY EFFICIENT
CAPITALS IN THE NATION.
I THINK IT'S VERY ASPIRATIONAL
AND I THINK IT'S ACTUALLY.
HISTORICALLY ACCURATE AND WHAT
A CAPITOL BUILDING WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE DONE.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
ARE JENNIFER WE'RE GONNA BE
PRESENTING TO YOU AND I HAVE
MARK YOU'RE HERE WILL BE TALKING
RIGHT AFTER ME AND DANIEL WEAVER
WILL TALK A LITTLE BIT AFTER
THAT WE'RE GOING TO TALK. ABOUT.
THESE ITEMS THAT ARE ON THE
AGENDA HERE.
THE SLIDES WILL GENERALLY START
WITH THESE TITLE SO YOU CAN
FOLLOW THROUGH. ONE OF THE OTHER
THINGS WILL BE SHOWING YOU A
SPECIFIC PAGES OUT OF THE BLOCKS
THE THE YOU CAN SEE THAT WHAT
WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO SHOW YOU
IS HOW TO READ THE BOOK AND HOW
TO FOLLOW THROUGH THE BOOK AND
WHY WE DID WHAT WE DID WITHIN
THE. REPORT.
REPORT.
IT'S LIKE.
.
SO PLANNING STUDY AND SUMMARY OF
STUDY EFFORTS.
THE PURPOSE FOR THE STUDY.
AS WE WERE SETTING OUT.
WAS TO ROUTE.
REMEDY THE EXISTING BUILDING
DEFICIENCIES AND ENHANCE THE
ABILITY. OF THE FACILITY.
TO MEET THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
NEEDS OF THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE.
WHAT YOU'LL FIND WITHIN THE
REPORT?
IS SECTIONS ASSOCIATED WITH
INFORMATION GATHERING AND
BACKGROUND.
GOAL SETTING.
WHICH WE CALL DESIGN GOALS.
IT'S LIKE.
PLANNING CONSIDERATIONS.
OF WHICH WE HAVE SOME TWO DOZEN
PLANNING CONSIDERATIONS
ILLUSTRATED WITHIN THE BOOK.
A FEW THOSE ARE SUCH THINGS AS.
MAINTAINING THE BEAUTY OF THE
HISTORICAL.
PARK AS WELL AS MAINTAINING THE
HIGHER KEY OF THE CAPITOL
BUILDING.
WHATEVER PLAYING CONSIDERATIONS
IS KNOWN STRUCTURAL DEFICIENCIES
THE BUILDING ITSELF WOULD HAVE
BASED ON STUDIES PROVIDED TO US.
THROUGH THE DG ES UM FACILITY
ASSESSMENT.
THERE'S KNOWN STRUCTURAL
DEFICIENCIES FOR SEISMIC AT FOR
YOUR TO COMPLY WITH TODAY'S
MODERN BUILDING CODES.
ONE OF THE OTHER ISSUES THAT I
THINK YOU'RE IS PARAMOUNT FOR
YOU TO CONSIDER IS.
DURING CONSTRUCTION.
IN ALL CASES EXCEPT FOR FIX IN
PLACE.
YOU WOULD NEED TO HAVE WHAT WE
CLASSIFY SWING SPACES WHICH ARE
SPACES WHERE THE PEOPLE IN THE
OCCUPANTS OF THE BUILDING AS
WELL AS THE PUBLIC THEMSELVES.
WOULD BE RELOCATED TO DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS.
AND THE.
THUS PRECIPITATING THE WHOLE
PUBLIC INFORMATION SYSTEM SO
THEY KNOW WHERE TO GO AND HOW TO
USE THE CAPITOL BUILDING DURING
CONSTRUCTION PROCESS.
AND. LASTLY I'LL JUST NOTE HERE
OUT OF THE TWO DOZEN WE HAVE.
THE DIRECT CONNECT OF THIS
BUILDING TO THE CAPITOL BUILDING
ITSELF THE.
HISTORIC UP NOBODY.
THAT HAS TO BE DONE IN A VERY
SENSITIVE SORT OF WAY AND DURING
CONSTRUCTION THAT'S ONE OF THE
CONSIDERATIONS IS MAKING SURE
THAT YOU HAVE NOT LEFT THE
ENVIRONMENT OF THE EXISTING.
HISTORICAL CAPITOL BUILDING
WHICH WILL MAY BE MAINTAINED.
AND IN A STATE WHERE IT CAN BE
UTILIZED BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT
YOU CAN UTILIZE THE CHAMBERS.
YOU CAN UTILIZE THE HEARING
SPACES IN THE MEETING ROOMS
WITHIN THE HISTORIC CAPITAL
WHILE THIS CONSTRUCTION GOES ON
BUT THAT WILL BE A PLANNING
CONSIDERATION DURING THE ACTUAL
DESIGN.
IF I MAY JUMP IN FOR JUST A
MOMENT YOU BETCHA ON THIS POINT.
A ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WE HAVE
IS WE HAVE TO CHAMBERS
THE HISTORIC CHAMBERS.
BUT AS SOON AS YOU STEP OUT OF
THE CHAMBERS FOR EXAMPLE THE
SENATE SIDE.
OUR THE MATTED LOUNGE THE DAVE
* LOUNGE
THE SERGEANTS OFFICE ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE YOU'RE VERY
USEFUL HEARING ROOM.
A THESE ARE ALL IN THE ANNEX.
SEVERE ADDRESSING THE ANNEX YOU
ACTUALLY AFFECT THE
FUNCTIONALITY OF THE CHAMBERS.
AND SO A LONG TERM STRATEGY HAS
TO WE HAD WE RETAIN THAT
FUNCTIONALITY. FOR THE MEMBERS.
THE OTHER THE OTHER ASPECT OF
THIS AND I WANT TO POINT TO THIS
CHART DO YOU SEE DOWN THERE THAT
COLORFUL CHART ON THE FAR WALL.
THAT'S ACTUALLY DO ONE THE
UNIQUE VALUE ADS OF THIS REPORT
DONE BY THIS FIRM.
AS HE TALKED TO PEOPLE.
THEY'VE.
KEPT TRACK OF WHERE TO MEMBERS
SPEND THEIR TIME.
WHEN A MEMBER RISE IN THE BILL
AND ONE OF THE THINGS YOU'RE
DOING DURING THE DAY.
AND THAT CHARTER IS BASS HE
SHOWS AT THE TOP YOU ENTER YOU
HAD YOUR OFFICE YOU CAN READ TO
HEARING ROOM. YOU MAY BE PRESENT
TO HER LONG RUN TO ANOTHER
HEARING WILL PRESENT A BILL BACK
TO THE ROOM.
YOU CAN GO TO SEE LEADERSHIP
PEOPLE GO TO CAUCUS YOU GO TO
CHAMBERS. YOU CAN VISIT ANOTHER
MEMBER.
WE GET A LOT DONE IN A VERY
COMPACT SPACE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE OF THIS ORIENTATION OF
WEST WING ANNEX.
THAT MAKES EVERYONE OF OUR DAYS
EXTRAORDINARILY PRODUCTIVE.
AND I WILL SAY IS ACTUALLY
PRETTY UNIQUE IS DEFINITELY
WASHINGTON MODEL.
AND MOST OTHER STATES LAWMAKERS
IN THAT HAVE.
HIKE ALL OVER THE PLACE TO GET
THEIR WORK DONE SO IT'S SORT OF
DEGRADES WHAT THEY CAN KNOCK OUT
IN A DAY.
SO I THINK AS HE TALKS ABOUT
THIS ISSUE OF. LOOK AT THESE
RELATIONSHIPS.
I WANT TO JUST PUT A FLAG ON
THAT CHART BECAUSE I THINK.
THAT REVEALS A LOT ABOUT HOW WE
ARE PRODUCTIVE.
.
PLEASE CONTINUE PARTLY.
I THANK YOU I'D ACTUALLY I I
AGREE WHOLEHEARTEDLY WITH WHAT
YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT WE HAVE.
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY.
INDIVIDUALLY AND IN DIFFERENT
GROUPINGS TO VISIT.
QUITE A FEW CAPITOL BUILDINGS
pFUNCTION ALSO AND HOW THEY'VE
DONE THEIR RENOVATION PROJECTS
I'VE. PERSONALLY BEEN TO ABOUT
TWELVE AMONG THE. EASTERN SIDE
OF THE UNITED STATES I'M GOT TO
TOO MANY SOUTHERN.
I CAPITALS BUT IT'S BEEN.
VERY NICK FOR US TO BECAUSE
YOU'RE CAPITOL BUILDING IS IN A
UNIQUE SITUATION WHERE YOU TOOK
A HISTORIC CAPITAL AND YOU PUT
THE OFFICE BUILDING.
DIRECTLY CONNECTED TO THE
CAPITOL BUILDING IN THAT DOES
NOT HAPPEN TERRIBLY OFTEN.
ULTIMATELY I GUESS IS WE WALK
THROUGH OUR REPORT WE.
.
LOOK THE TABULAR DATA. AND THIS
IS ESSENTIALLY SPREADSHEETS.
.
WE LOOKED AT THE SURVEYS AND
REPORTS THAT HAVE BEEN DONE IN
THE PAST.
WE LOOKED AT INFORMATION WAS
PROVIDED TO US THAT WAS FROM THE
SIXTIES FROM THE SEVENTIES.
AND SOME INFORMATION WE HAVE
FROM THE EIGHTIES. THAT
INFORMATION HELPED FEED OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE
DESIRES AND NEEDS FOR THE
CAPITAL WERE OVER A LONG PERIOD
OF TIME.
THE WORLD IS CHANGED A LOT SINCE
SOME OF THOSE STUDIES WERE OUT
THERE.
GOVERNMENT WAS A PART TIME
LEGISLATURE AND OF WHICH IT IS
NOT NOW.
AND THE WAY THAT THE PUBLIC
ACTUALLY CAN GET TO AND GET
INFORMATION FROM THE CAPITALIST
CHANGE SIGNIFICANTLY.
THE SPREADSHEETS THEN TALLY UP
THE.
WAY THE CURRENT BUILDING WORKS
AND THE ADJACENT SEASON ARE
CURRENTLY WITHIN THE BUILDING TO
LOOK FOR. IT EITHER ADVANTAGES
OR DISADVANTAGES ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT AS WELL AS WHEN WE DID
PROJECTIONS. BASED ON OUR
CONVERSATIONS AND BASED ON A
PROGRAMMING EFFORT WHICH WILL
TALK ABOUT LATER. TO HOW MANY
PEOPLE.
THE BUILDING ACTUALLY NEED TELL
ME HEARING ROOMS THE BUILDING
ACTUALLY NEEDS AND WE WE.
BALANCE THOSE TWO.
.
SPREADSHEETS OFF OF EACH OTHER
AND ULTIMATELY.
WE.
WENT THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
PROVIDING YOU WITH IN THE BOOK.
CONCLUSIONS OR RECOMMENDATIONS.
SO THE NEXT LIKE PLEASE SO NOW
WHAT I WANT TO DO IS JUST TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT SOME OF
THOSE EFFORTS WERE TO CREATE
SOME OF THE SECTIONS WITHIN THE
BOOK.
.
THE INFORMATION GATHERING
UNKNOWN DOCUMENTS AS I SAID WAS
TO CALL THROUGH HISTORIC
DOCUMENTATION.
GENERATE.
.
INFORMATION BASED ON THE KNOWN
AND EXISTING FACILITIES THAT YOU
CURRENTLY HAVE.
AND TRY TO ANALYZE WHY IS IT
BEING DONE THAT WAY.
THERE WAS DIFFICULT FOR US TO
ACTUALLY INITIALLY UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY WHILE THE SINK WHEN
TOGETHER BUT AS WE WENT THROUGH
THIS PROCESS WHICH WE USE ALL OF
THESE SMALL BITS OF DETAILS TO%
UNDERSTAND YOUR GOVERNMENT
HOPEFULLY BETTER THAN YOU
UNDERSTAND HOW YOU WORK WITHIN
YOUR OWN WALLS BECAUSE. YOU'RE
DOING A JOB AND WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO SEE HOW YOUR GHOSTS ARE
MOVING AROUND.
PARTICIPATING IN HIGH LEVEL
GOAL SETTING MEETINGS
THIS RIGHT HERE IS A POIGNANT
TIME WITHIN THE PROJECT BECAUSE
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS. WHAT
WOULD YOU ASPIRE TO HAVE THIS
BUILDING TO?
DOES THE CURRENT BUILDING APPLY
WELL TO YOUR ASPIRATIONS OF WHAT
YOU WOULD LIKE THIS BUILDING TO
DO.
WE WENT THROUGH THE PROCESS WE
TALK TO.
CAPITAL OCCUPANTS AND LEADERS
TWO I GENERATE A LIST OF GOALS
WHICH DANIEL WEAVER WILL WALK
YOU THROUGH HERE IN A FEW
MINUTES.
WE CONDUCTED INTERVIEWS AS I'VE
MENTIONED A COUPLE TIMES THOSE
INTERVIEWS WERE YOU INTERVIEWED
SOME FIFTY PLUS PEOPLE. AND TALK
TO MORE THAN THAT BUT.
WE DID ACTUALLY ARTICULATE ALL
THEIR NAMES BUT MOST OF THOSE
ARE ILLUSTRATED WITH IN THE
BOOK.
OF THE PEOPLE THAT SAT DOWN WITH
US AND GAVE US INFORMATION WE
TOLD THEM THAT WE WOULD TAKE
THEIR INFORMATION WITHOUT. BIAS
TO THE INFORMATION AND WE DIDN'T
NAME ANYBODY FOR THEIR SPECIFIC
INFORMATION THEY GAVE US SO THEY
FEEL COMFORTABLE IN TELLING US
ANYTHING THEY WANTED TO TELL US
AND WE THINK WE GOT A VERY
HONEST.
AN OPEN CONVERSATION WITH THEM.
ULTIMATELY WHAT WE DID IS WE
GENERATED A. A PROGRAMMING
DOCUMENT WHICH ALL ALSO TALK
ABOUT LATER ON HERE.
WHICH IS A SPREADSHEET OF
DESIRED ROOMS IN SIZES.
AND EVENTUALLY HERE AS I SAID WE
DEVELOPED.
.
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
OUR RECOMMENDATION WHICH IS
ILLUSTRATED WITH IN THE BOOK.
IS THAT YOU WOULD REMOVE AND
REPLACE THE EXISTING CAPITAL
ANNEX.
IT STRUCK THE NEW APPROPRIATELY
SIZED.
ENERGY EFFICIENT CAPITAL ANNEX
IN THE SAME LOCATION.
OUR ASSUMPTIONS ARE WITH THAT
RECOMMENDATION THAT YOU WE
COMPLY WITH ALL MODERN CODES.
ALL ACCESSIBILITY NEEDS.
AND BE VERY INCLUSIVE IN THE
PROCESS.
SO AT THIS POINT.
TIRED HEAR ME TALK ABOUT PASSES
ON TO MARK YOUR WHO IS GOING TO
WALK YOU THROUGH THE EXISTING
BUILDING DEFICIENCIES AND THEN
PROGRESSED TO.
CASA GRADUATION.
THANKS JOHN.
THIS SLIDE THAT SHOWN IS FROM
PAGE TEN
THE PLANNING BOOK.
AND OUR PRESENTATION THIS
MORNING IS BASED ON THE BOOK AND
SO IS JOHN MENTIONED WE WILL
OCCASIONALLY SHOW SLIDES DIRECT
FROM THE BOOK JUST ORIENT YOU AS
WE GO ALONG.
IN ON THIS ON THIS PAGE THERE'S
A.
TWELVE.
.
TWELVE DEFICIENCIES ARE TWELVE
GENERAL CATEGORIES FOR DEFEAT
SEES THAT WE FOUND WITHIN THE
BUILDING.
AND GETTING ALL THE DEFICIENCIES
LUMPED INTO DIFFERENT CATEGORIES
IS A BIT OF A CHALLENGE.
REALLY WHAT WE WERE LOOKING FOR
HERE'S DEFICIENCIES.
BUT LIMIT THE ROLE OF THE ANNEX
FULLY ACHIEVING ITS.
ROLE AS A VENUE.
FOR GOVERNMENTAL PROCESSES BUT
ALSO FOR ALLOWING FOR FOR.
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION SO THOSE
WERE OUR FOCUS FOR BUILDING
EFFICIENT.
IT WILL GO THROUGH THESE
INDIVIDUALLY NOW BUT THEY'RE
LOCATED ON PAGES TEN TO THIRTY
OF THE BOOK.
FIRST ONE LIFE SAFETY BUILDING
CODE DEFICIENCIES WE MENTION
THIS BEFORE. AND AND PRIMARILY
TO THE AGE OF THE ANNEX THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT LIFE SAFETY
DEFICIENCIES THAT EXIST WITHIN
THE BUILDING.
AND JUST TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW.
ACCESS TO EXITS
IT'S WHAT WE MEAN BY THAT IS
REALLY THE THE ABILITY FOR AND
IN INDIVIDUAL WHO WORKS IN THE
BUILDING OR A GUEST TO GET TO
THAT EXIT.
BUT ALONG THE WAY THERE'S GOING
TO BE EXIT WITH IMPACT
IMPAIRMENTS AND WE SEE EXIT
WITS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT'S OF
HALLWAYS BUT WERE ALSO TALK
ABOUT WHAT THE DOORWAYS AT A
SPACES AND WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
WHAT'S OF STAIRWAYS SO IT'S IT
IMPACTS THE HORIZONTAL
CIRCULATION AS WELL AS THE
VERTICAL CIRCULATION.
NOT ENOUGH WITH SIMPLY PUT.
AS MENTIONED BEFORE THE FIRE
SPRINKLER SYSTEM IS NOT
COMPREHENSIVE THROUGHOUT THE
BUILDING IT THERE IS A LIMITED
AMOUNT DOWN IN THAT IN SOME
PARTS OF THE BASEMENT IS WHERE
THAT DOES EXIST.
AND IF AND ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF A.
CHO DEFICIENCY IS IF THE IF THE
BUILDING WAS BUILT TODAY IF THIS
ANNEX WAS BUILT UNDERSEA MODERN
BUILDING CODES IT WOULD HAVE
MORE LATERAL BRACING MORE
SEISMIC BRACING EARTHQUAKE
EARTHQUAKE BRACING.
DID WHAT THIS BUILDING CURRENTLY
HAS.
THE SECOND ONE IS NON COMPLIANCE
WITH THE AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITIES ACT THE EIGHTY
EIGHT.
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING CODE IN
AND AGAIN LARGELY DUE TO THE AGE
THE BUILDING. AND AND BUT THESE
ARE PROBLEMS THAT IMPACT THOSE
WHO WORK IN THE BUILDING. BUT
ALSO IMPACT.
ACCESS FOR THE PUBLIC TO GET
INTO THE BUILDING IN TO MEET
WITH THEIR MEET WITH THEIR
LAWMAKERS.
SO REALLY ALL PAP O. PUBLIC
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO THIS
BUILDING THIS MOST IMPORTANT
PEOPLE'S HOUSE AND IN THE
BUILDING SHOULD NOT LIMIT.
IN IN SOME CAPACITY
RIGHT NOW IT DOES.
THE SPECIFIC SPECIFICS OF THAT
ACCESS OR FOR WORK SPACES.
MEETING AREAS AND TOILET
FACILITIES THE TOILET
FACILITIES.
IS I'M SURE IS GENERALLY KNOWN
ARE THERE'S TOO FEW OF THEM AND
WHEN YOU'RE IN THEIR THEIR TOO
SMALL SO JUST ACCESS TO THOSE.
IS DIFFERENT IMPEDIMENT.
ONE OTHER.
.
SLIGHTLY MORE DETAILED ITEM IS.
IN IN HERE IN A ROOM SUCH AS
THIS THERE'S WAYS TO HAVE A
LITTLE BIT BETTER ENHANCEMENTS
FOR IMPROVED ASSISTED LISTENING.
SYSTEMS FOR THOSE WHO HAVE VOTE
THE PUBLIC WHO COMES IN AND AND
MAYBE HEARING IMPAIRED.
SUSTAINABLE DESIGN ISSUES IS
ANOTHER DEFICIENCY THAT WE
IDENTIFIED IN JUST REAL SIMPLY
PUT THE EXISTING. ANNEXES NOT
ENERGY EFFICIENT.
THE I THIS BUILDING SHOULD
STRIVE TO BE A NET ZERO. ENERGY
FACILITY.
EXISTING ENVELOPE AND EXISTING
SYSTEMS WITHIN THE BUILDING JUST
DON'T.
CURRENTLY ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN.
ANOTHER FOSTER A COUPLE OF THE
FAUCETS OF SUSTAINABLE DESIGN
THOUGH IS.
MATERIAL ON SYSTEM SELECTION
IN A SUSTAINABLE BUILDING THAT
MATERIALS SHOULD BE LONG LASTING
SHOULD BE TIMELESS EASILY
MAINTAINED.
AND REDUCE GLOBAL GLOBAL WARMING
POTENTIAL.
AND CURRENTLY NOT ALL THE
SYSTEMS IN AND FINISHES IN THIS
BUILDING MEET THAT CRITERIA.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST IDEALLY
IN ASSISTING WILL DESIGN
BUILDING HERE A BUILDING WITH
SUSTAINABLE DESIGN YOU HAVE.
FIXTURES THAT ARE LOW WATER USE
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SINKS
WERE TALKING ABOUT TOILETS MORE
TALK ABOUT URINALS.
OVERCROWDING IS IS OUR FOURTH
DEFICIENCY IN THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT ONE AND WE HEARD
ABOUT THIS.
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT DURING OUR
INTERVIEWS BUT WE'VE ALSO
OBSERVED IT FIRST HAND THAT
PROBABLY EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM
IS OBSERVED THIS FIRST HAND.
PARTICULARLY DURING THAT DURING
SESSION OF COURSE BUT THERE'S
CONGESTION IN THE HALLWAYS BUT
THERE'S ALSO CONGESTION IN THE
BACK WORK AREAS THAT A LOT OF
THE PUBLIC MAY NOT EXPERIENCE OR
SEE.
AND SO THERE'S CODE IMPACTS
TO THIS OVERCROWDING.
BUT ALSO THE THE OVERCROWDING
CREATES BUILDING OR CREATES
BUSINESS INEFFICIENT.
THE. THIS ENGINE DOESN'T CHURN
QUITE AS WELL AS IT COULD IF IT
HAD A LITTLE MORE SPACE A LITTLE
MORE.
MORE ROOMS MORE MEETING ROOMS
PARTICULARLY.
AND OVERCROWDING THOUGH DOES IT
IN
TO US LIMIT THE PUBLIC'S ABILITY
TO COME IN AND.
ME WITH THEIR ELECTED OFFICIALS
OR PERHAPS TESTIFIED A PUBLIC
HEARING.
NEXT IMAGE PLEASE.
A SAFETY OF USER CONCERNS THAT
WHAT WE'RE REALLY TALKING ABOUT
HERE IS SECURITY FOR THE
BUILDING OCCUPANCY GAS.
AND WE DID DURING OUR INTERVIEWS
HAVE DISCUSSIONS LIKE THE
DISCUSSIONS ON SECURITY.
AT THAT DO NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
BUT THEY BASICALLY FALL INTO TWO
GENERAL CATEGORIES.
ENHANCING TECHNOLOGY.
THE SECURITY SYSTEM SHOULD BE
STATE OF THE ART SIMPLY PUT.
BUT ALSO THERE'S SOME PHYSICAL
ENHANCEMENTS
COULD BE DONE TO THE BUILDING
AND SOME OF THESE ARE
SIGNIFICANT
FOR EXAMPLE TAKING THE PARKING
THAT'S CURRENTLY. UNDERNEATH THE
BUILDING FOOTPRINTS AND MOVING
THAT OUT FROM UNDERNEATH THE
BUILDING FOOTPRINT THAT'S A A
PHYSICAL RESTRAINT RIGHT NOW TO
THE BUILDING THAT COULD BE
ADDRESSED.
CONFUSING WAY FINDING AND PUBLIC
ACCESS AND THESE ISSUES START
WITH THE SITE.
WHEN PEOPLE APPROACH THE
BUILDING.
I THINK A LOT OF FIRST TIME
USERS THEY WANNA GRAVITATE
TOWARD THE STORK WEST WING. IS A
APPROACH THIS THEY REALIZED TO
GET IN THEY NEED TO GO OVER TO.
A LITTLE DIFFERENT AREA FOR
THOSE TO GAIN ENTRY TO THE
SECURITY CHECKPOINTS.
AND THIS CREATES CONGESTION IF
THOSE CHECKPOINTS AND
IMMEDIATELY BEHIND THAT ON THE
NORTH SIDE THERE'S THE.
THE COUNTY DISPLAYSTHAT
CREATES A BOTTLENECK IMMEDIATELY
AFTER ENTRY.
BUT INTERNAL CIRCULATION ONCE
THEY'RE IN THE BUILDING THERE IS
THAT CONFUSION IN A LOT OF THIS
IS THE SIZE OF THE BUILDING.
INHERENT IN THE NATURE OF
BUILDING THE SIZE IN ITS
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE WEST WING
THE THE DIFFERENCES IN ELEVATION
BUT JUST THE THE SIZE OF THE
BUILDING.
SO THAT WAY FINDING IS AN ISSUE
THAT SHOULD BE
SHOULD BE ADDRESSED.
FEELING TOILET AND PLUMBING
SYSTEMS.
I MITCHELL BEFORE THERE'S
INSUFFICIENT TOILET ROOMS.
BUT ALSO DRINKING FOUNTAINS THEY
SHOULD HAVE BOTTLED WATER
FILLERS IDEALLY ON THEM. AND WE
USE THE TERM FAILING TOILET
THERE BECAUSE WERE AWARE OF
SOME.
FEELING PIPES THAT HAVE
LITERALLY BURST THERE'S BEEN
SOME LEAKS THERE'S BEEN SOME
PROBLEMS IN THE BUILDING BETTER.
LOCALLY ON ONE FLOOR BUT ALSO
IMPACTED THE FLOOR BELOW.
AT LEAST AGING MECHANICAL
SYSTEMS AND DURING THE
INTERVIEWS WE WE HEARD A GREAT
DEAL ABOUT PROBLEMS WITH THERMAL
COMFORT.
AND A D. G. S. DID GET
COMPLIMENTED ON THEIR WRISTS.
IT'S PROBLEMS.
YOU'RE GOOD.
A AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST WITH
THE AGEING MECHANICAL SYSTEMS
ARE JUST SIMPLY NOT ENERGY
EFFICIENT.
UNDERSIZED ELECTRICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE WE DID ANALYZE
THE EXISTING AMPERAGE INTO THE
BUILDING THE.
WHAT COOL JUICE INTO THE
BUILDING AND FOUND IT TO BE
UNDERSIZED IN OUR REPORT IT'S IN
THE REPORTED IT'S IDENTIFIED
THERE AND MORE? THE TECHNICAL
ASPECTS OF THAT BUT IT IS LOW.
BUT ALSO THE POWER DISTRIBUTION
WITH IN THE BUILDING IS
OUTDATED.
FOR EXAMPLE IF THERE IF THERE
NEEDS TO BE A REPAIR DONE IN THE
BUILDING IT APPEARS TO US THAT A
LARGE CHUNK OF THE BUILDING
MIGHT NEED TO BE TAKEN OFF LINE
TO DO THAT REPAIR. IS OPPOSED TO
A MORE ADVANCED.
OR SOME MODERN ELECTRICAL
BACKBONE THAT WOULD ENABLE A
LITTLE BUT MORE NIMBLE AND
TACTICAL ABILITIES TO DO SMALL
REMODELS UPGRADES IS THEY NEED
IS A NEED TO BE DONE.
COINCIDENTALLY WITH THAT
OUTDATED TECHNOLOGY.
IS THE BUILDING HAS GROWN IN
TECHNOLOGY IS GROWN. THE ACT.
A COMMUNICATION SYSTEMS WITHIN
THE BUILDING AND TO THE OUTSIDE
OF THE BUILDING ARE. THERE PUT
WHERE THEY COULD FIT.
THAT DOESN'T ALWAYS MEET CODE.
IN IT CLOSETS ARE NOT DENTED
NOTE HAVE A SIMPLE EXAMPLE OF
THE TECHNO TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCEMENTS THAT COULD HAPPEN.
INADEQUATE CONFERENCING SPACES
THIS IS THIS IS A HUGE ONE AND.
IT'S A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM WITH
IN THE ANNEX.
THERE SHOULD BE MORE FORMAL
HEARING ROOMS.
IN A VARIETY OF SIZES
BUT ALSO MORE INFORMAL SPACES.
IN THE INFORMAL SPACES OR OUR
SOME OF WHAT THE PUBLIC DOESN'T
SEE BUT WHAT WE'VE OBSERVED IS.
IF THERE NEEDS TO BE MEETINGS
HELD WITHIN WORKERS WHO WORK AT
THOSE WHO WORK IN THE BUILDING
THERE'S JUST SIMPLY NO. GOOD
PLACE FOR THEM TO DO THAT.
AND ALSO THOUGH THAT LIMITS THE
ABILITY TO THE PUBLIC TO COME
AND NOW WE'VE HEARD NUMEROUS
TIMES OF.
THE PUBLIC COMES IN THERE'S NO
GOOD THEY WANT TO MEET WITH
THEIR.
.
MEET WITH SOMEONE THERE'S NO
GOOD PLACE TO DO THAT THOSE CAN
SPELL OUT INTO THE HALLWAY. AND
NOT AN IDEAL SITUATION.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST OTHER
PUBLIC AND WORKING SPACE
DEFICIENCIES.
OF THE WHAT'S ON THE SLIDE THERE
HAS.
A NUMBER OF THOSE ON THE LIST
GOT PRIMARILY THOSE MISALIGNED
FLOORS IS ONE THAT I THINK
IMPACTS THE THE FUNCTION OF THE
BUILDING.
AND THE ALSO THOUGH AMENITIES
FOR WORKERS FOR ENHANCING THEIR
ABILITY TO DO THEIR JOBS IN AN
EXPEDITIOUS WAY.
NEXT UP.
WE WANT TO TALK.
ABOUT ESTIMATED.
INSTRUCTION COSTS.
AND ON THE NEXT SLIDE. IN THIS
IS FROM PAGE EIGHTY.
OF THE PLANNING STUDY BOOK THERE
WERE THREE.
COST EVALUATIONS DONE. THE FIRST
IS REMOVAL AND REPLACEMENT OF
THE ANNEX
THE OTHER ONE IS NEW PARKING
STRUCTURE.
IN A NEW VISITOR CENTER AND
PUBLIC ACCESS THOSE OF THE THREE
COSTS YOU SEE HERE IN THOSE AND
WE DID THESE THREE SEPARATE
COSTS BECAUSE THEY REALLY NEEDED
TO BE EVALUATED DIFFERENTLY.
FROM ONE ANOTHER AND WE WANTED
TO BUDGET AN APPROPRIATE AMOUNT
FOR EACH ITEM.
SO MOVING INTO THE REMOVAL AND
REPLACEMENT OF THE ANNEX.
THE EVALUATION WAS DONE.
PRICING OF AN APPROPRIATELY
SIZED.
NEW ANNEX.
OUR VALUATION WAS DONE ASSUMING
THAT NEW ANNEX WOULD BE VACATED.
AND THE CONSTRUCTION WOULD BE
DONE ALL AT ONCE.
AND IT IS JOHN MENTIONED EARLY
EARLIER JOHN ALLUDED TO ITS ITS
MOST EFFICIENT TO DO IT THAT WAY
WITH WE FEEL ITS MOST EFFICIENT
FOR THE GOVERNMENT. TO MAINTAIN
ITS PROCESSES
FOR THE BUILDING TO BE
HOLISTICALLY DONE AT ONCE. BUT
ALSO FROM ITS CONSTRUCTION
STANDPOINT IT'S MOST EFFICIENT
THAT WAY AS WELL TO TRY TO LIMIT
THE CONSTRUCTION DURATION.
SWING SPACES HORSE WILL SPACES
FOR RELOCATION THAT JOHN TALKED
ABOUT ARE ARE NOT IN THE
ESTIMATE. IN THERE'S THERE'S
THREE DIFFERENT VEHICLES FOR
ACHIEVING THOSE SWING SPACES
WHERE WHERE THE WHERE THE
BUSINESS NEEDS TO HAPPEN DURING
CONSTRUCTION.
AND IT COULD BE NEW CONSTRUCTION
COULD BE BUILT NEW NEW SQUARE
FOOTAGE COULD BE PROVIDED FOR
THAT OR IT COULD BE. A EXISTING
SPACE BE REMODELED WERE THIRD
COULD BE.
RENTAL RENTING EXISTING SPACES
AND AND BASED ON OUR PAST
EXPERIENCE RENTING IS USUALLY
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
GO. BUT THERE MAY BE SOME
COMBINATION DEPENDING ON
AVAILABILITY OUT THERE THAT
WOULD DETERMINE THOSE IMPACTS IN
THOSE THOSE PRICES.
SO THAT WOULD BE A STUDY THAT
WOULD NEED TO BE.
IT WOULD NEED TO BE DONE.
OUR BUDGET CONSTRUCTION COST.
FOR REMOVAL AND REPLACEMENT
ANNEXES APPROXIMATELY FIVE
HUNDRED SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
ON THE NEW PARKING STRUCTURE ON
THE SLIDE OUR EVALUATION
INCLUDED REMOVAL OF THE PARKING.
FROM UNDERNEATH THE BUILDING AND
PROVIDING A NEW PARKING
STRUCTURE SEPARATE FROM THE
ANNEX.
IN THE SIZE OF THIS WAS DONE BY
OUR INTERVIEWS ARE OURS DURING
THE INTERVIEW PROCESS TO
DETERMINE THE SIZE OF THAT. BUT
ALSO INCLUDES LOADING DOCK AND
GOVERNOR'S PARKING AREA.
IF IT IF IT REMAINS ON SITE.
IT PROBABLY SHOULD BE
UNDERGROUND.
TO.
.
MAINTAIN VIEWS TO THE CAPITOL TO
MAINTAIN THE CHARACTER. OF THE
CAPITOL MALL. IT IT DOESN'T HAVE
TO BE UNDERGROUND OR IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE.
ON SITE IT COULD BE IN SOME
ADJACENT LOT ARE ARE ARE COST IS
IT SO ASSUMING IT TO BE
UNDERGROUND ADJACENT TO THE
CAPITAL. AND WE HAVE SOME ROUGH.
APPROXIMATION STUDIES OF THIS
BUT HAVEN'T DONE ANY GREAT OUT
WAIT TO SEE WHERE IT WOULD FIT.
A BUDGET COST BUDGET
CONSTRUCTION COST OF THIS SIX
AND A HALF MILLION.
IN LAST PUBLIC ACCESS VISITORS
CENTER FOR THE FIFTY PLUS YEAR
LIFESPAN OF THE BUILDING.
WE WANT TO MAXIMIZE PUBLIC
ACCESS TO PRIORITY.
AND THESE COSTS ADDRESS SITE IS
THE APPROACH TO THE SITE.
ACUITY ENTRIES BUT ALSO AREAS
WITHIN THE ANNEX.
DO COST TO INCLUDE OUR PREFER
PROVIDING FOR A NEW VISITOR
CENTER. FOR THE PUBLIC.
AND THIS WOULD BE REALLY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE THE
VISITOR EXPERIENCE IS THEY
APPROACHED THE CAPITAL.
A COULD FUNNEL THEM INTO THE
WEST WING WHERE A GREAT DEAL OF
THEM WANT TO GO.
THERE'S INTERACTIVE DISPLAYS
THAT COULD EARLY BE STAGED IN
THAT PROCESS EVEN AS EARLY AS
SOME OF THE SCREENING PROCESS
FOR THAT GROUP.
TO GO THROUGH SO THE EXPERIENCES
IS A A A GOOD ONE FOR THEM.
AND THAT WOULD FREE UP SOME
TRAFFIC IT SOME OF THE OTHER
WORKADAY.
ENTRANCES.
ALSO THOUGH IN THIS IN THIS
ANALYSIS WE LOOKED IT SQUARE
FOOTAGE WITHIN THE ANNEX FOR
WIDER CIRCULATION AREAS.
PACIFIC WE AREAS WHERE LAWMAKERS
CAN MEET WITH THEIR CONSTITUENTS
WE WANT WE WANT TO HAVE THOSE
THAT THE APPROPRIATE SQUARE
FOOTAGE.
IN THE CIRCULATION SYSTEM SO
THAT PUBLIC ACCESS IS GRANTED.
OUR BUDGET COST BUDGET
CONSTRUCTION COST FOR PUBLIC
ACCESS VISITORS CENTER.
IS APPROXIMATELY THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
DANIEL WILL TALK NEXT.
ABOUT DESIGN GOALS ITS ALTERNATE
OVER TO HER.
THANK YOU MARK.
THE NINETEEN DESIGN GOALS FOR
THIS PROJECT CAN BE FOUND ON
PAGES THIRTY EIGHT TO SIXTY FOUR
IN YOUR BOOKS.
LEAST GOALS FOR RETIREMENT TO
BE THE MOST IMPORTANT IDEAS OF
THE PROJECT.
I WILL PROVIDE THE FUTURE DESIGN
TEAM WITH GUIDANCE THROUGHOUT
THE DESIGN PROCESS.
THE GOALS EMERGED FROM
STAKEHOLDER WORK SESSIONS AND
INTERVIEWS THAT JOHN MENTIONED
EARLIER.
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE RUN THROUGH THESE DESIGN
GOALS SO THAT EVERYBODY CAN COME
BECOME MORE FAMILIAR WITH THEM.
THE FIRST DESIGN GOAL IS
TRANSPARENCY AND OPENNESS.
MAINTAINING TRANSPARENCY AND
OPENNESS IS IMPORTANT.
OVER TIME WE'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OBSERVE NUMEROUS
STATE GOVERNMENTS AN OPTION IN
OPERATION.
BUT MOST ARE NOT AS ENGAGING AS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE INTENT OF THE NEW DESIGN IS
TO ENHANCE PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
IN THE GOVERNMENTAL PROCESS. AND
REMOTE ACCESS TO MEMBERS BY
REORGANIZING THE OFFICES AND
CONFERENCE ROOMS AND PROVIDING
CLEAR PATHWAYS AROUND THE
BUILDING.
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE PUBLIC
FEEL COMFORTABLE WHEN VISITING
THE CAPITOL AND PARTICIPATING IN
THE GOVERNMENTAL PROCESS.
SOME EXISTING PHYSICAL BARRIERS
HINDER THIS ENGAGEMENT
SUCH AS INADEQUATELY SIZE
CONFERENCE ROOMS.
THE NEW DESIGN TO PROVIDE
INVITING SPACES TO PARTICIPATING
GOVERNMENTAL PROCEEDINGS AND
SHOWCASE THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE.
DIGNITY.
DIGNITY AND GOVERNMENT FOSTERS
PRIDE IN CALL TRY DANITY.
EVERYONE WHO WORKS AND AND
VISITS CAPITAL SHOULD FEEL A
SENSE OF DIGNITY DIGNITY AND
PRIDE FROM THE TIME THEY ENTERED
THE BUILDING UNTIL THE EXIT THE
CAPITOL GROUNDS.
THE ANNEX DESIGN CHAU PROVIDE A
QUALITY EXPERIENCE FOR ALL USERS
BY INSTILLING DIGNITY AND PRIDE.
AS WELL AS BY PROVIDING A
CONNECTION TO CALIFORNIA'S
CULTURE AND HISTORY.
ENTRY IN THE VISITOR EXPERIENCE.
AS YOU ALTHOUGH THE CAPITAL
HOSTS APPROXIMATELY ONE AND A
HALF TO TWO MILLION VISITORS A
YEAR. INCLUDING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF SCHOOL CHILDREN.
.
THIS LEADS TO VERY CONGESTED
ENTRYWAYS AND HALLWAYS AT THE
COUNTY DISPLAYS WHICH WE'VE ALL
EXPERIENCED.
THE NEW DESIGN WILL PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DEDICATE AN AREA
FOR GUESTS AND SCHOOL CHILDREN
TOGETHER FOR A MORE MEANINGFUL
EXPERIENCE.
THIS DEDICATED AREA SHOULD
ENGAGE THE GUESTS WITH
INTERACTIVE DISPLAYS AND BE ABLE
TO ACCOMMODATE LARGE CROWDS.
THERE SHOULD ALSO BE CLEAR
DIRECT ROUTES FOR THOSE WISHING
TO DO BUSINESS WITH IN THE
CAPITAL.
FUNCTIONALITY.
A FUNCTIONAL DESIGN WILL ENABLE
USERS TO EFFICIENTLY A
COMFORTABLY CARRY OUT THEIR
DAILY ACTIVITIES.
IS NOT PHYSICALLY POSSIBLE TO
RENOVATE THE CURRENT BUILDING TO
FUNCTION AS DESIRED DO ITS SIZE
AND STRUCTURAL CONFIGURATION.
FOR EXAMPLE WE'VE HEARD FROM OUR
INTERVIEWS WITH USERS THAT MANY
CONVERSATIONS OCCUR IN THE
CORRIDORS. LACK TO.
DUE TO LACK OF INADEQUATE
MEETING SPACES.
IT COMPOUNDS THE CONGESTION IN
THE HALLWAYS.
THE NEW ANNEX DESIGN SHOULD
HOUSE ALL DESIRED FUNCTIONS
INCLUDING THESE CASUAL
CONVERSATION SPOTS IN THE
CORRIDORS.
THE NEXT GOAL IS HIERARCHY.
HIGHER KEY OF SIGNS ACCORDANCE
TO AREAS OF BUILDING THROUGH
SHEEP SIZE LOCATION AND LEVEL OF
FINISH.
PRINCIPLES OF HIGHER KEY EVIDENT
IN THE HISTORIC CAPITAL SHALL BE
CARRIED THROUGHOUT THE NEW
DESIGN OF THE AND.
CURRENTLY AS YOU MOVE BETWEEN
THE TWO BUILDINGS.
EVIDENT THAT THE ANNEX WHO WAS
NOT COORDINATED ALL ON THE
DESIGN WITH THE HISTORIC
CAPITAL.
HISTORIC CONNECTION AND
RELEVANCY.
CURRENTLY THERE'S VERY LITTLE
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE HISTORIC
CAPITAL IN THE ANNEX.
THE MISALIGNMENT OF THE FLOORS
IS MARK DISCUSSED.
AND THE SEMI INSTITUTIONAL
FINISHES OF THE ANNEX GIVE IT OF
DRASTICALLY DIFFERENT FEEL.
THE GOAL OF THE ANNEX DESIGN
SHOULD BE TO STRENGTHEN THE
CONNECTION.
BETWEEN AN ACCENT HISTORY
CAPITAL WITHOUT OVERSHADOWING
THE STORK RELEVANCY OF THE
CAPITAL.
THIS CAN BE ACCOMPLISHED BY
INTRODUCING SIMILAR MATERIALS
AND SYMBOLISM THAT IS CURRENTLY
FOUND THROUGHOUT THIS STORY
CAPITOL. ONE OF THE SYMBOLS IS
THE CARVED WOULD BEAR THAT YOU
SEE IN THE PICTURE HERE.
NEXT SLIDE.
NATURAL LIGHTEN VIEWS WE HEARD
FROM ALMOST EVERY STAKEHOLDER
THAT NATURAL LIGHTING VIEWS ARE
VERY IMPORTANT TO THE FUTURE
DESIGN OF THE ANNEX.
THE NEW DESIGN CHAU USE NATURAL
LIGHT THROUGHOUT THE BUILDING
TOMORROW HEALTH AND WELL BEING.
THE USE OF NATURAL LIGHT ALSO
REDUCES THE NEED FOR ARTIFICIAL
LIGHT. REDUCING ENERGY
CONSUMPTION AND COSTS.
LIFE SAFETY.
AS PREVIOUSLY NOTED THE ANNEX
DOES NOT COMPLY WITH CURRENT
BUILDING CODES.
IN PARTICULAR.
IT'S LACKING A FIRE SPRINKLER
SYSTEM AND HAS INSUFFICIENT
EXITING OUT OF THE BUILDING.
FIRST BANQUET SYSTEM SAVE BOTH
AYE BUILDING OCCUPANTS AND
FIREFIGHTERS LIVES.
THEY CAN ALSO LIMIT DAMAGE TO
BUILDINGS STRUCTURES DURING A
FIRE.
THE NEW ANNEX DESIGN SHOULD BE
DESIGNED TO MEET OR EXCEED ALL
BUILDING CODES.
IT WILL PROVIDE A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL USERS
INCLUDING THOSE WORKING IN THE
BUILDING.
TWO GROUPS VISITORS AND SCHOOL
CHILDREN.
ACCESSIBILITY.
ACCESSIBILITY MEANS PROVIDING
EQUAL ACCESS FOR ALL USERS
REGARDLESS OF ABILITY.
SINCE THE INTRODUCTION OF THE
AMERICAN WITH DISABILITIES ACT
EIGHTY A. IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE
THE BILLING HAS UNDERGONE
NUMEROUS RENOVATIONS TO IMPROVE
ACCESSIBILITY.
HOWEVER IT IS NOT BEEN ABLE TO
BE BROUGHT FULLY AT TO THE ADA
IN CALIFORNIA TITLE TWENTY FOUR
STANDARDS. AS THE LAW REQUIRES
DUE TO MANY BARRIERS WITHIN THE
BUILDING.
THE NEW ANNEX DESIGNED SHOULD BE
FULLY ACCESSIBLE AND PROMOTE
THAT SEAMLESS EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
ACCESS SHOW WE WERE PROVIDED TO
ALL PUBLIC ACCOMMODATIONS.
ACCESSIBLE DESIGN SHOW EXTEND TO
ALL ASPECTS OF THE BUILDING
INCLUDING STAIRS.
RAMPS DOOR HARDWARE SEATING
SIGNAGE PLUMBING FIXTURES
ELEVATORS AND MUCH MORE. THE
LIFT THAT SEEN IN THIS PICTURE
HERE'S ONE OF THOSE THAT WE
WOULD ACTUALLY LIKE TO GET RID
OF. AND PROVIDE ACCESS TO ALL
THAT IS NOT OUT OF THE WAY AND
INCONVENIENT AS THIS WITH
CURRENTLY IS.
SUSTAINABLE DESIGN.
IT IS BEEN STATED THAT THE ANNEX
SHOW SET AN EXAMPLE FOR ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND BE AMONGST THE
MOST ENERGY EFFICIENT CAPITALS
IN THE UNITED STATES.
SUSTAINABLE DESIGN NOT ONLY
REFERS TO ENERGY EFFICIENCY BUT
ALSO EXTENDS TO BUILDING
MATERIALS DELIGHT WASTE THE
BUILDING SITE. TECHNOLOGY AND
ALL OTHER BUILDING SYSTEMS.
THE GOAL WOULD BE A MINIMUM OF A
LEAD SILVER CERTIFICATION ON THE
BUILDING.
THE NEW ANNEX DESIGN SHOW ALSO
INVESTIGATE HIM IMPLEMENT.
AS IN MANY SUSTAINABLE DESIGN
MEASURES AS FEASIBLY POSSIBLE.
INCLUDING EXPLORING THE USE OF
ALTERNATIVE ENERGY CONSUMPTION.
SYSTEM SUCH AS SOLAR PANELS.
SAFETY OF USERS.
MAINTAINING THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF BUILDING USERS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
EVERYTHING FROM BUILDING ACCESS
AND EXITING TO PARKING A FIRE
SPRINKLER SHOULD BE CONSIDERED
IN THE NEW DESIGN.
OVER TIME THE BILLING HAS HAD TO
ADAPT TO MORE STRINGENT SECURITY
MEASURES SUCH AS THE SECURITY
PAVILION SEEN HERE. IN THE
PHOTO.
THE NEW AN ACTUAL BE DESIGNED TO
INTEGRATE CURRENT SECURITY
MEASURES WITHIN THE DESIGN OF
THE BUILDING HAVE BE FLEXIBLE TO
ACCOMMODATE FUTURE MEASURES.
WHY ME?
SURE ON.
THERE'S A NEW FEDERAL
COURTHOUSE.
NEW FEDERAL COURTHOUSE IN
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES.
THAT.
IN SEPTEMBER. IN TWENTY SIXTEEN.
ARE LIKE THREE WEEKS MORE OPEN
THE DEPUTY US MARSHAL GAVE ME A
TOUR OF THIS NEW.
NEW FEDERAL COURTHOUSE.
AND THE THING THAT STRUCK ME WAS
HE SAID.
THAT.
HE WAS IN THE ROOM ON BEHALF OF
THE U. S. MARSHALL LOS ANGELES
COUNTY ON THAT DAY EVERYONE
FIRST FILED IN THE ROOM.
TO START A CONVERSATION OR NEW
COURTHOUSE.
AND SO HE HE JUST EXPRESS THIS
IDEA THAT. IF YOU GET YOUR
SECURITY TEAM IN THE
CONVERSATION EARLY.
THEN YOU ARE ABLE TO HAVE A.
EIGHT.
REAL STRONG THREE SIXTY VIEW OF.
HOW TO MAKE THE SECURITY THING
WORK SECURELY?
AND YOU CAN INTEGRATED IN THE%
DESIGN AND THAT'S THE MOST
AFFORDABLE WAY TO GO.
SO THAT'S WHY LAST YEAR WE HAD
OUR.
DENNIS CAPTAINCIES PR OWN
SERGEANTS IN THE CONVERSATION.
SO THIS BECOMES A VERY IMPORTANT
THING TO DO EARLY BECAUSE IS SO
SO NEEDED TODAY AND IT BECOMES
MORE COST EFFECTIVE TO START TO
COME.
GREAT THINK YOU AND THAT'S
REALLY INDICATIVE OF THE ENTIRE
PROCESS WE WOULD WANNA BRING IN.
ALL DIFFERENT.
ENTITIES SUCH AS SECURITY
ACCESSIBILITY AND THE DIFFERENT.
PEOPLE WHO WOULD HAVE AN
INFLUENCE ON THE DESIGN OF THE
PROCESS EARLY TO HAVE BEEN A
SUCCESSFUL DESIGN.
MECHANICAL ELECTRICAL SYSTEMS
IS THE NEXT DESIGN GOAL. AS THE
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED THE CURRENT
MECHANICAL AND ELECTRICAL
SYSTEMS WITHIN THE ANNEX OR
INEFFICIENT AND INADEQUATE FOR
THE CURRENT BUILDING NEEDS.
NEW MECHANICAL ELECTRICAL
SYSTEMS ARE NOT ONLY GOOD FOR
THE BILLING USERS ARE ALSO GOOD
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT.
THEY PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REMOVE POTENTIALLY HARMFUL
EQUIPMENT FROM THE BUILDING AND
PROVIDE STATE OF THE ART LOW
IMPACT EQUIPMENT.
THE NEW AN EXTRA HAVE MODERN
ELECTRICAL MECHANICAL SYSTEMS
THAT ARE ENERGY EFFICIENT. USE
APPROPRIATE AMOUNTS OF FRESH AIR
HAVE USER FRIENDLY CONTROLS AND
ARE ADAPTABLE TO FUTURE NEEDS.
TECHNOLOGY.
WHEN UNIX WAS CONSTRUCTED THE
DESIGNERS COULD NOT SEE OR
PREDICT THE ADVANCES IN
TECHNOLOGY AND THE LIFE. OUR
LIFETIME WOULD SEE OVER TIME
TECHNOLOGY HAS BEEN INTRODUCED
TO THE BUILDING. BUT IT'S STILL
NOT UP TO MODERN STANDARDS.
RESIDING IN THE TECH CAPITOL OF
THE WORLD WILL PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAP INTO THIS
KNOWLEDGE. AND APPLY IT TO
FUTURE DESIGN.
THE NEW HEADACHES SHOULD BE
DESIGNED TO INTEGRATE MODERN
TECHNOLOGY TO ALL SPACES THEY'RE
FLEXIBLE DEDICATED PATHWAYS.
ALLOWING FOR EASY UPGRADES IN
THE FUTURE.
A DECENT SEIZE.
AND THIS IS THE CHART THAT WAS
REFERRED TO.
BACK THERE ON THE BOARD.
THE FUTURE ANNEXES NINE SHOW
CONSIDER THE NEEDS OF ALL
DEPARTMENTS AND FUNCTIONS TO
PROVIDE A MORE EFFICIENTLY OUT
EVERY USERS. AND MAKE NAVIGATION
THROUGH THE BUILDING MORE
INTUITIVE FOR VISITORS.
THE CALIFORNIA CAPITAL IS UNIQUE
IN ITS CURRENT DESIGN AND THAT
THE HISTORIC CAPITOL BUILDING
WAS EXPANDED UPON IS THE STATE
GREW RATHER THAN. BUILDING A
SECOND OFFICE BUILDING.
THIS ALLOWS ALL ASPECTS OF THE
GOVERNMENT TO WORK CLOSELY
TOGETHER AND HAVE DIRECT ACCESS
TO THE CHAMBERS AND OTHER
CEREMONIAL ROOMS WITHIN THE
HISTORY CAPITAL.
UNFORTUNATELY THE BUILDING HAS
ONCE AGAIN BECOME TOO SMALL TO
HOUSE ALL DESIRED FUNCTION.
BASED ON OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
USERS.
IT IS DESIRED TO MAINTAIN THIS
WORKING ADJACENCY.
PRESENCE IN THE BUILDING.
BASED ON OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
USERS THERE IS A DESIRE TO
CONSOLIDATE GOVERNMENTAL
FUNCTIONS INTO THE ANTICS.
THIS WILL EVERYONE TO HAVE A
PRESENCE IN THE BUILDING AND
REDUCE TRAVEL TIME BETWEEN THE
VARIOUS BUILDINGS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY USE.
MEETING SPACES.
CURRENTLY MEETING SPACES ARE
OFTEN OVERCROWDED.
THE BUILDING ALSO LACKS ENOUGH
VARYING SIZES A MEETING SPACES
INCLUDING INFORMAL CONFERENCE
SPACES.
UPGRADES TO EXISTING MEETING
SPACES AND THE ADDITION OF NEW
MEANING SPACES WITHIN THE
CURRENT ANNEX BUILDING HAS BEEN
HINDERED BY THE EXISTING
STRUCTURE COLUMN LAYOUT. WHICH
IS NOT CONDUCIVE TO CREATING
LARGE OPEN SPACES.
THE NEW DESIGNS OFFER A VARIETY
OF MEETING SPACE TYPES AND
INCORPORATE MODERN TECHNOLOGY.
DISPLAYS.
CURRENTLY VISITOR DISPLAYS ARE
SPREAD OUT THROUGHOUT THE
BUILDING WITH NO DEDICATED
CENTERED OR ANTI ONESELF.
THE NEW ANNEX DESIGN SHALL
STRIVE TO INCORPORATE ENRICHED
VISITORS PLAYS TO PROMOTE
LEARNING. ABOUT THE STATE AND
GOVERNMENT.
THE ANNEX DESIGN SHOW ALSO
CREATE PATHWAYS FOR THOSE
WANTING TO EXPERIENCE THE
HISTORY OF THE CAPITOL. AND
THOSE WANTING TO CONDUCT
BUSINESS WITHIN THE CAPITAL TO
ALLEVIATE CONGESTION AND
CONFUSION.
THE LAST GOAL IS CAPITAL PARK
AND VIEWS TO THE CAPITAL.
THE NEW ANNEX DESIGN CHAU
REINFORCED THE HISTORIC
IMPORTANCE OF THE SURROUNDING
CAPITOL PARK.
RATHER THAN DETRACT FROM IT.
THE NEW DESIGN CHILL STRIVE TO
MAINTAIN VIEWS TO THE HISTORIC
CAPITAL. AND PROTECT MEMORIALS
WITHIN THE PARK.
ANY ADDED STRUCTURES MUST BE
SUBSERVIENT TO THIS STORY
CAPITAL.
TO MAINTAIN THE STATURE IN
BEAUTY OF THE GRAND BUILDING AND
SURROUNDING PARK.
NOW I THINK WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO PROGRAMMING IN WHICH JOHN
WILL GIVE YOU A BRIEF OVERVIEW
OF THAT PROCESS.
WELL DEFINED WHAT PROGRAMMING
MEANS.
BECAUSE PROGRAMMING IS A WORD
USED BY ALL DIFFERENT KINDS OF
INDUSTRIES AND.
THE A INDUSTRY.
PROGRAMMING IS ESSENTIALLY AND
EVALUATION OF THE SPACE NEEDS.
WITHIN A STRUCTURE.
AND THE ADJACENCY IS ASSOCIATED
WITH THOSE SPACE MEANS.
UNDERSTANDING THE NEEDS OF THE
ANNEX USERS.
.
YEAH AND HOW THEY ACTUALLY WORK
WITH IN THE BUILT ENVIRONMENT IS
PART OF THE PROGRAMMING PROCESS.
THE.
ONCE AGAIN THE.
DIAGRAM THE SHOWN BACK THERE AS
WELL AS ONE DANIEL MENTION IS
ONE OF THE END RESULTS OF THAT.
THE PROCESS ITSELF NEEDS TO
RESOLVE WHO NEEDS TO BE IN THE
BUILDING.
AND SHOULD BE IN THE BUILDING
AND WHO DOESN'T NEED TO BE IN
THE BUILDING AND WHO DOESN'T
NEED TO BE IN THE BUILDING.
OR DOESN'T WANT TO BE IN ITALY.
.
WE WE.
SIX OR THE PROGRAMMING TO FIND
OUT HOW MANY SQUARE FEET THE
ACTUAL BUILDING.
WOULD NEED TO INCORPORATE TO BE
ABLE TO SATISFY THE.
FUTURE OF THE PROJECT IN THE
FUTURE NEEDS OF THE PROJECT AND
LOOKING AT THIS WE'RE TRYING TO
BE.
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
.
INTO THE FUTURE NOT JUST IN WHAT
DO YOU NEED TODAY
WHAT WOULD YOU NEED THE FUTURE.
SLIDE.
SO.
ON THIS SIDE HERE WHAT WE'RE
GONNA TALK JUST A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT IS.
KIND OF THE HIGHLIGHTS OF THE
KIND OF PROGRAMMING.
THAT.
.
WE PROVIDED.
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT WAS A HEAVY
CONVERSATION THAT WE HAD WITH
EVERYBODY ABOUT HOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO.
ENGAGE THE PUBLIC
TO GO TO WHAT SOME OF WHAT
DANIEL MENTIONED THAT SOME OF
WHAT MARK TALKED ABOUT AS.
DEFICIENCIES WITHIN THE
BUILDING THERE NEEDED TO BE MORE
CLEAR AND SPACIOUS AREA FOR THE
PUBLIC TO COME INTO THE
BUILDING.
TO ALLOW THEM TO HAVE THEIR.
.
USE OF THE BUILDING WITHOUT.
BEING DETRIMENTAL TO THE REST OF
THE FUNCTIONS IN THERE SO THE
WAS A HIGHLIGHTED IMPORTANCE.
TO GET.
PUBLISHED USER AND PUT ON HOW
THEY USE BUILDING AND HOW THEY'D
LIKE TO USE THE BUILDING AND
STATE OF JUST.
HAVING US TELL THEM HOW THEY GET
TO USE THE BUILDING.
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT SPACES WERE
PART OF THE PROGRAMMING EXERCISE
WE EVALUATED HOW BIG A SPACES
AND HOW MANY SPACES WERE NEEDED.
AND A LOT OF THAT WAS IN THE
WAYS OF MEETING SPACES.
I HEARING SPACES AND OTHER.
AMENITIES THAT ALLOWED PEOPLE
TO ENGAGE IN THEIR GOVERNMENT AS
WELL AS JUST VISIT AND HAVE A
GOOD TIME IN YOUR BUILDING.
BETTER PUBLIC WAITING SPACES.
WAS HIGHLY.
SOUGHT DURING THE INTERVIEWS
AND SO SPACES NEED TO BE.
CONFIGURED IN SUCH A WAY WHERE
THE PUBLIC IS NO LONGER.
.
REQUIRED TO SIT ON BENCHES OUT
THE QUARTERS.
WHICH.
BOTH INHIBITS EXITING AS WELL
AS DOES NOT ACTUALLY PROVIDE
.
COMFORTABLE.
AWAITING ENVIRONMENT.
WE WE WOULD THINK THAT THERE IS
A POTENTIAL FOR LOUNGES EVER
SPACES WHERE PEOPLE COULD WATCH
THAT.
.
LEGISLATURE IN ACTION THAT COULD
ALSO FUNCTIONS SOME OF THESE
PUBLIC WAITING SPACES.
CREATING AN ADDITIONAL HEARING
ROOMS OF VARYING SIZES.
PROVIDE THE PUBLIC WITH GREATER
ACCESS AND ENGAGEMENT.
THE BUSINESS OF THE GOVERNMENT.
IT'S HIGHLY DESIRED.
WE'VE ADDED IN THE PROGRAM THE
PROGRAMS WERE FOOTAGE.
THESE ASPECTS INTO THE PROJECT
WHICH ACTUALLY.
.
IN MOST WAYS BROUGHT ALMOST ALL
THE HEARING SPACES BACK INTO THE
CAPITAL UNICODE SOLID DATED
SPECIFIC LOCATION ALLOWING
PEOPLE TO GO FROM ONE HEARING TO
ANOTHER HEARING. EITHER AS A.
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE GOVERNMENT
OR THE PUBLIC TRYING TO ATTEND
MULTIPLE HEARINGS WITHOUT HAVING
TO TRAVERSE THE LAWNS ARE YARDS
OUTSIDE.
MORE COMMON USE AREA.
WITH A.
PLANNING STUDY IDENTIFIED.
INEFFICIENT
AND.
ESSENTIALLY A VERY LOW NUMBER
OF PUBLIC UTILITIES THAT WERE
AVAILABLE.
THERE'S NO.
.
I GUESS
WAS NO LIMIT TO THE AMOUNT OF
TOILET ROOMS YOU CAN PUT INTO
THE BUILDING OTHER THAN YOU
CAN'T BE LESS THAN A CERTAIN
NUMBER AND YOU GUYS ARE WELL
BELOW THE THE LOWEST NUMBER
FOR AYE TOILET FACILITIES WITHIN
THE BUILDING YOU COULD ADD MORE
AND WHAT WE WOULD SUGGEST IS
THAT.
THROUGH THE PROGRAMMING WHAT WE
DECIDED WAS THAT IF YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE A LARGE NUMBER OF
HEARING SPACES YOU'LL HAVE.
A CONSOLIDATED AREA OF TOILET
FACILITIES AVAILABLE FOR THOSE
BECAUSE OF THE LARGE NUMBER OF
USERS THAT WOULD BE THERE. BUT
THROUGHOUT THE REST OF THE
BUILDING YOU WOULD HAVE
APPROPRIATE NUMBERS OF TOILET
FACILITIES KNOWS ARE ALL
IDENTIFIED WITHIN THE PROGRAM AS
FAR AS NUMBERS GO.
CONFERENCE ROOMS WORKROOMS EXIT
STAIRS ELEVATORS ALL OF THOSE
WHICH FALL WITHIN THE NORMAL
EVERYDAY ACCESS POWS.
WERE.
SEEN IN THE PREVIOUS.
IN THIS EXISTING BUILDING AS
BEING AN ADEQUATE. AND IN
PROGRAMMING THOSE NUMBERS WERE
GROSSED OUT TO ALLOW FOR.
BETTER.
DISBURSEMENT THROUGHOUT THE
BUILDING AND I'LL OF PEOPLE.
I GUESS BETTER ACCESS TO THOSE.
CONSISTENCY OF SPACE PLANNING
AYE AND DESIGN WAS ONE OF THE
DESIRES BY MOST OF THE PEOPLE WE
TALKED TO. THERE'S TOO MANY
INCONSISTENT SPACES.
AND IT'S DIFFICULT FROM OFFICE
TO OFFICE TO KNOW HOW.
HOW THOSE WHO ARE CONFIGURED?
AND SO SOME CONSISTENCY WITHIN
OUR MODEL WE.
IDENTIFIED A CERTAIN SIZE OF
SPACE FOR A TYPICAL OFFICE A
TYPICAL FUNCTION A TO. A
TYPICAL.
MEMBERS OPPOSITE. OFFICE SUITE.
AND SO ON.
WAS ACTUALLY IDENTIFIED AND
THAT WAS WHAT WAS IDENTIFIED
WITHIN THE SPACE PROGRAM. AND
CLEAR ACCESS
PATHWAYS WE.
GROSSED UP THE NUMBERS TO ALLOW
FOR THE CONGESTION IS IT'S.
CIRCULATION AND CERTAIN AREAS
WITHIN THE BUILDING TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT WAS EASIER TO GET
AROUND.
WAS SAFE FOR FIRE.
.
PROTECTION PERSONNEL.
AT AT THIS POINT IN TIME THEY
THERE IS A. SERIES OF NOTES
SAYING THAT WHEN YOU HAVE A
LARGE NUMBER PEOPLE SPREAD OUT
THROUGH THE QUARTERS IT'S A LOT
HARDER FOR PEOPLE TO GATHER THEM
TOGETHER IN A.
I EMERGENCY SITUATION.
IN CONCLUSION.
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS AND NOW THE
REASON YOU'RE SAYING TO IS
BECAUSE I'M GOING TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT PROGRAMMATIC KLAY.
PROGRAMMATIC LEE WE THINK THAT
THE.
WE NEED TO PROVIDE GREATER
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT AND MEETING
SPACES.
THROUGHOUT FOR THE STAKEHOLDERS
AND NEEDED BY THE USERS WITHIN
THE BUILDING INCREASING THE AREA
OF THE CAPITAL ANNEX BUILDING.
ULTIMATELY THE OF THE PREVIOUS
RECOMMENDATION WE STATED ALREADY
STATED THAT ITS JUST NOW YOU CAN
ACTUALLY SEE THE PERIOD AFTER
THE SENTENCING NEED MORE SQUARE
FOOTAGE WITHIN THE BUILDING.
SO THE REMOVAL AND REPLACEMENT
OF THE EXISTING CAPITAL ANNEX.
AND CONSTRUCTING A NEW
APPROPRIATELY SIZED ENERGY
EFFICIENT.
AND I WOULD ADD IN HERE ALSO
CODE COMPLIANT ACCESSIBLE.
CAPITOL ANNEX BUILDING IN THE
SAME LOCATION.
BRINGS US TO THE AND OF OUR.
.
PRESENTATION AND WE'RE OPEN FOR
QUESTIONS.
SENATOR LEYVA. GOOD MORNING I
STEPPED OUT FROM AND I APOLOGIZE
BUT OPPOSITE THIS IS BEEN
ADDRESSED PLEASE TELL ME TO STOP
TALKING.
IS THERE ANY THOUGHT TO.
CREATING ADDITIONAL CHILDCARE
SPACE.
I KNOW WE HAVE WE OFFER
CHILDCARE HERE AT THE CAPITOL
BUT IT'S.
WOEFULLY INADEQUATE FOR AS MANY
PEOPLE THAT WORK HERE IS THERE
ANY THOUGHT TO THAT.
I SPECIFICALLY OUT GIVEN.
SPECIFICALLY WE DID LOOK AT THAT
AND THAT IS PART OF THE NUMBERS
WITHIN THE. PROGRAM WHY DON'T
KNOW RIGHT OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD IF WE EXPANDED THAT ARE
CONTRACTED OUT OR OF WHAT THAT
WAS BUT.
OURS WAS AN INITIAL PROGRAM TO
MAKE SURE WE KIND OF UNDERSTOOD
HOW BIG THE BUILDING ONCE I
THERE'S A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY
WITHIN OF ALL THIS WILL.
PLAY OUT AND SO IT EASILY COULD
BE PART OF THE PROCESS OKAY
GREAT MISTER CHAIRMAN I'D LIKE
TO PUT IN A PLUG FOR ADDITIONAL
CHILD CARE. DULY NOTED I THINK
HE TALKED AND AND ONE OTHER
QUESTION I GUESS I KNOW HOW TO
OF FREEZE IT NOW MISTER CHAIRMAN
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO PUT IN A
PLUG.
WE HAVE A LOT OF OUR MEMBERS
WHO ARE STARTING MEMBERS AND
STAFF WHO ARE STARTING TO BIKE
TO WORK. IF NEED BE WHEN WE ARE
THINKING ABOUT THE NEW GARAGE
THERE'S A PLACE IN THE GARAGE.
FOR LOCKERS MAYBE EVEN A COUPLE
SHOWER STALL SO PEOPLE COULD
BIKE TO WORK TAKE A QUICK
SHOWER.
REDUCE OUR CARBON FOOTPRINT KEEP
EVERYBODY ACTIVE AND HEALTHY.
JUST ANOTHER SUGGESTION
WELL I DON'T THINK THAT WOULD
FIT WITHIN THE SUSTAINABLE
DESIGN PRINCIPLES.
IT IS EXPECTED THAT. ANYTHING
WE DO WILL. PURSUE. APPROPRIATE
LEAD CERTIFICATION COMPLY WITH
GOVERNOR'S DIRECTIVES AT A
MINIMUM.
.
AND.
SO BY KEENAN ALL MANNER OF
THINGS LIKE THAT I THINK WOULD
BE A PART OF THAT CONVERSATION.
.
I I THINK THAT WOULD BE A GIVEN
GREAT.
IF I MAY I HAVE MORE ON THAT ONE
FOR YOU A WAS ACTUALLY INCLUDED
WITHIN THAT.
PARKING. STRUCTURE ALREADY.
BECAUSE IT WAS A FAIRLY STRONG
TOPIC WHERE EVERYBODY SAID HEY
EVERYBODY'S RIDE THEIR BIKES OR
GLORIA FOR BIKES AND SO. I THINK
YOU'RE ECHOED BY MANY PEOPLE WE
TALKED TO.
IF I MAY TURN OUT TO CENTER
MOROCCAN AND TO YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHURN.
I'M JUST CURIOUS.
I KNOW YOU'VE HAD A FUN TIME
REVIEWING THE ANNEX.
COULD YOU EXPLAIN WHY. THE
DESIGN WHO WAS SORT OF AWKWARD
DID YOU GET ASSEMBLYMEMBERS IN
THE BASEMENT DOOR. AND YOU KNOW
WE GOT OFFICES NEXT ELEVATOR
DOORS.
DID DID YOU EVER FIND OUT.
WHY IT WASN'T?
NUMBER.
BUT WE DO YOU CAN YOU DIG INTO
THE RHYME OR REASON FOR SOME OF
THE DESIGN FEATURES.
WE DID ACTUALLY LOOK AT ALL.
KIND OF HISTORIC DOCUMENTS AND
THE COMPLAINTS THAT HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING SINCE THE SIXTIES.
HONESTLY.
WHAT WE WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT
AS YOU GUYS GREW YOU RAN OUT OF
SPACE AND PEOPLE JUST TOOK
WHATEVER SPACE I COULD POSSIBLY
DO AND IT'S MOVED?
SHIFTED MANY TIMES THROUGHOUT
ITS HISTORY OF BEING HERE IT WAS
NOT I DON'T THINK.
INTENDED TO HAVE SOME OF THE
SPACE IS OCCUPIED AS OFFICE
SPACES BECAUSE SOME OF THOSE.
DREADFUL OFFICE SPACES AND
QUITE HONESTLY I DON'T BELIEVE
MOST OF THOSE ACTION COMPLY
WITH.
BUILDING CODES.
OKAY AT LEAST NOT TODAY'S
BUILDING CODES AND I'M PRETTY
SURE THAT MAY NOT HAVE COMPLIED
WITH BUILDING BECAUSE OF THAT
SPECIFIC POINT TIME. BUT YOU YOU
HAVE.
.
I'D.
QUOTE UNQUOTE.
.
THE BUILDING IS A STRAIGHT
JACKET FOR EXPANSION AND.
WITH THAT THAT MEANS THAT YOU
HAVE TO KIND OF FIT WHATEVER YOU
CAN WITHIN THE TIGHT ENVELOPE
THAT YOU HAVE AND SO.
WE CAN IDENTIFY Y. ALTERNATELY
PUT ON THERE BUT WE KNOW THAT IT
WAS BECAUSE YOU JUST HAD NOWHERE
ELSE TO PUT THEM.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT WAS EVER
THE INTENTION OF WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED.
ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH THE
STRUCTURAL STEEL PROCUREMENT
LAW.
CALIFORNIA.
I DON'T KNOW THAT ONE OKAY. FREE
YOU MIGHT WANT TO CHECK INTO
THAT IT'S BEEN KIND OF AN
AWKWARD DILEMMA FOR PROJECTS.
ESPECIALLY CALTRANS AND I JUST
WANNA KNOW IF IT'S. ALSO.
PERTINENT TO THIS CERTAIN*.
LIKE IS NOT GETTING EMAILS FROM.
VENDORS THAT HURDLE FRUSTRATED.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT TIMING AND
THIS IS MAYBE A MULTI.
LONG QUESTION BUT.
WHO WE WERE ABLE TO BUILD?
IN THE COUNTY OF ORANGE TERMINAL
C. TO THE JOHN WAYNE AIRPORT.
WE BUILT IT STARTING ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT WHEN WE WERE IN A
RECESSION WE WERE ABLE TO GET.
GREAT BIDS
YOU NO ASSEMBLY A CONSTRUCTION
COSTS WERE LOWER BECAUSE THERE
WAS JUST NOT A LOT OF.
GOING ON I WAS TELLING MATURE
THAT I WOULD TO WERE. THE
CONSTRUCTION EVERY SIX WEEKS BUT
THE HARD HAT ON THE.
HARD SHOWS YOU KNOW TO. THE
CHOOSE.
IN THE END THE EMILY EMPLOYEES
WHICH ARE PART OF JUST THANKS
FOR HELPING US SO WE WE BUILT
THAT WAY UNDER BUDGET.
AND SO WE HAVE THESE ECONOMIC
CYCLES
ITS OATH STATE IS ISSUING BONDS
AND EVERYBODY'S BUILDING NEW
SCHOOL BUILDINGS AND. ALL THIS
ACTIVITIES GOING ON WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO COMPETE MAYBE PAY MORE
WAIT LONGER. AND AND I'M JUST
CURIOUS I KNOW YOU DON'T SEE THE
FUTURE BUT HOW DO WE. HOW DO WE
TIME IT WERE AT THE OTHER DAY
WAS A POINTED WE BUILD THIS?
AT THE RIGHT TIME IS WE.
COMMUNICATE TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
THAT WE'RE DOING THE RIGHT
THING.
I THINK THIS VERY QUESTION.
WHEN WE DID OUR ANALYSIS FOR.
ARC ARE COSTING WHAT WE DID IS
WE TOOK INDUSTRY STANDARDS FOR
WHAT ESCALATION IS ACROSS THE
TEN YEAR PERIOD AND WE TALK AND
EVALUATION OF.
A WHOLE LOT OF YOUR CAPITOL
BUILDING OUR ERA COURTHOUSE
BUILDINGS I GOT BUILT OVER THAT
AMOUNT OF TIME WE DIDN'T
EVALUATION ON THAT AND. WHAT IT
SHOWED TO US IS THAT YEARS AGO
THERE WAS?
LESS ESCALATION THEN THERE IS
YOUR CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING BUT
OVERALL THAT ESCALATION WAS TWO
POINT FIVE.
I THINK TODAY AND TODAY'S WORLD
IS A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
ENVIRONMENT THAN ALL OTHER TIMES
THAT WE'VE HAD A SOURCE
CONSTRUCTIONS CON BECAUSE
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
CONSTRUCTION GOING ON IN THE
UNITED STATES. IN THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS WE DON'T HAVE A
CRYSTAL BALL TO TELL US WILL
THAT CONTINUE.
WE DO KNOW THAT WITH.
WITH THIS KIND OF PROJECTS TO
BANG AND HOW YOU APPROACH THEM.
AS YOU PROCEED TO END OF THE
DESIGN CYCLE THE DESIGN CYCLING
SELF WILL PROBABLY TAKE.
JUST TO GARNER ENOUGH AGREEMENT
FROM EVERYBODY THAT WOULD BE
INVOLVED IN DESIGN CYCLE
PROBABLY TWO YEARS AND MAYBE TWO
AND A HALF YEARS JUST TO GET TO
THE POINT WHERE YOU ACTUALLY
READY.
TO DO THE CONSTRUCTION BECAUSE
THERE'S LOTS OF OTHER LOGISTICS
HAVE TWO ONE THREE THAT PROCESS
OF SUCH AS WHERE IS EVERYBODY
MOVING TO.
AND.
EVERYTHING ELSE.
THERE'S THERE'S A LOT OF
TELECOMMUNICATION ISSUES THAT
COME UP THAT HOW DO YOU REMOTE
THOSE TO DIFFERENT LOCATIONS IN
ALL THE SINK SO THERE'S A LOT OF
THE JUST SIX THE HASTERT HAPPEN
BEFORE YOU CAN ACTUALLY. PUT A
SPADE IN THE GROUND.
ONCE THAT'S ALL DONE THE
CONSTRUCTION ITSELF WILL
PROBABLY TAKE ABOUT.
THREE YEARS JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU DO IT.
APPROPRIATELY A COULD TAKE A
LITTLE BIT LONGER BUT I.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IN TODAY'S
SOCIETY WE CAN BUILD THIS
BUILDING IN THREE YEARS.
WITH THAT THOUGH.
.
DEPEND WHAT YOU'RE TRENDS ARE IF
YOU DO DECIDE AT THIS POINT TIME
OUR ACROSS THE STATE TO.
YOU'VE ALREADY DONE A LOT OF
THE.
THE COURTHOUSE PROJECTS WHICH
WAS A SIGNIFICANT.
INSTRUCTION EFFORT BUT IF YOU DO
REBUILD A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
YOUR EDUCATIONAL FACILITIES
ACROSS THE NATION ARE YOU HAVE
LARGE.
DANCES OF CONSTRUCTION THAT GO
ON THAT WILL MODIFY POTENTIALLY
THE AVAILABILITY OF. LABOR TO
WORK ON THE BUILDING.
.
AND YOU WILL WE WOULD SUGGEST
THAT YOU ACTUALLY MODERATE THEN
POTENTIALLY WHAT THE SCHEDULE IS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT SO YOU
DON'T FORCE ANYTHING TO RAPIDLY
THAT CAR COST YOU MORE MONEY AND
SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE GIVING YOU A
LITTLE BIT LONGER PERIOD TO WORK
THIS OUT SO YOU CAN.
SPREAD THAT AND. MAKE SURE YOU
FIND THE MANPOWER AVAILABLE FOR
THE CONSTRUCTION PERIOD AS IT
MIGHT FALL.
.
BY THE SAME TOKEN IT MIGHT BE.
MORE COST EFFECTIVELY DO A
QUICKER AND SO THAT THE ECONOMIC
ANALYSIS THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
HAVE TO BE TAKEN INTO A PLACE.
SO IF YOU LOOK FORWARD AND YOU
CAN FORECAST AT ALL THOSE
SCHOOLS WILL BE BUILT HERE BUT
WE COULD FIND A WAY TO ACTUALLY
GET THIS MOVING FORWARD EARLIER.
YOU'RE BUYING A CONTRACT PRIOR
TO.
ALL THOSE OTHERS IT'S
DETRIMENTAL TO YOUR STATE ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER SOMEBODY'S
GONNA HAVE TO PAY A LITTLE BIT
MORE FOR THEIR BUILDINGS IF YOU
TRY TO BUILD THEM ALL THE SAME
TIME.
AND I GENERAL CONSTRAINT JUST AN
OBSERVATION FOR MY COLLEAGUES ON
THE COMMITTEE. WE YOU PROBABLY
END UP.
TIMING THE PROJECT GENERALLY TO
WHEN YOU WOULD KICK IT OFF.
AND WOULD BE MOVING BACK AND
TO THE FALL OF AN ODD NUMBERED
YEAR.
SO IT'S PROBABLY NOT OPPORTUNE
TO BE ENGAGED IN DESTRUCTION OF
OFFICES WITH WHOLESALE MOVES.
A HUNDRED TWENTY LAWMAKERS.
IN THE FALL DURING IN THE
ELECTION CYCLE YEAR.
YEAH AND AND THIS IS THIS WAS
THE CASE WHEN THEY DID THE WEST
WING.
YOUR KEY MOVES HAPPEN IN THE
FALL YOUR KEY TRANSITION FROM
ONE FACILITY TO A NEW FACILITY
HAPPEN IN THE FALL OF THAT ODD
NUMBERED YEAR.
SO I JUST.
I SORT OF THINK WE NEED TO.
LOOK AT THAT LOOK AT THE STUDIES
THAT NEED TO BE DONE THE
GROUNDS.
THE SWING SPACE AND WE'RE
PROBABLY TALKING FOR THE BIG
MOVES.
THAT NEED TO HAPPEN.
TO TRANSITION FROM ONE
ESTABLISHED SYSTEM WITH ALL THE
PARTS WORKING TO SUPPORT OUR
GOVERNMENT'S.
TO ANOTHER ESTABLISHED SETTING
WITH ALL THE PARTS WERE TO
SUPPORT OUR GOVERNANCE. HAS
HAPPENED THE FALL OF NINETEEN
TWENTY ONE NINETEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND SO YOU THAT THAT'S BECOMES A
PRACTICALITY.
THAT WE HAVE A WORKING TO THE
GOVERNMENT.
SUPPORTING THE EXECUTIVE AND
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH.
AND THE WELCOMING PUBLIC AND WE
NEEDED TO HURRY UP TRANSITION
FROM ONE TO THE OTHER.
TO FACILITATE PROGRESS THAT'S
ANOTHER MARKER. THAT'LL AFFECT
WHERE WE.
WHERE WE ARE THE CYCLE? BUT WE
JUST PERFECT I THINK WE JUST
WE NEED TO PROCEED WITH ALACRITY
AND DO THE PLANNING STUDIES.
.
THERE ARE WAYS TO ENHANCE IT ONE
OF THE THINGS WE DID OUR PROCESS
WAS ON A WEEKLY BASIS I
ASSURANCE. CENTER MORLOCK WE PUT
TOGETHER STAFF PHONE CALLS.
ON A WEEKLY BASIS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE ARCHITECTURAL TEAMS WAS
MIDDLE PICK THE BRAIN OF THE
TEAM ON THIS AND.
TWO SHORT CYCLE THINGS AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE.
AND I THINK THAT'S SORT OF
THINKING WE WANTED TO
AGGRESSIVELY ON THE PUBLIC'S
BEHALF.
AND AND THEN YOU ARE IN CONTROL
YOUR SCHEDULE IF YOU'VE DONE
YOUR WORK UP FRONT AND YOU CAN
PICK THE OPPORTUNE. TIME TO
PROCEED
EARLIER BAD TURN TO SENATOR
MITCHELL YOU HAVE A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION ONO YOU MUST.
TURN TO SENATOR MITCHELL.
SENATOR MITCHELL THANK THANK YOU
SENATOR MOORE LA.
I WOULD FOLLOW UP ON MY
COLLEAGUES I INQUIRED TO WITH
REGARD TO CHILDCARE.
.
AND I HOPE.
THAT A PART OF YOUR PLANNING
THAT THAT SOME TIME AND EFFORT
WILL BE SPENT.
IN HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
CURRENT VENDOR THEY'RE DOING AN
ASSESSMENT OF AVAILABLE CHILD
CARE SLOTS.
FOR STATE EMPLOYEES IMMEDIATE
AREA I KNOW THE FACILITY CLOSE
FOR SOMETIME APPEARED OF TIME
AND I'M NOT SURE WHY IT IT SEEMS
TO US THAT ON THE OUTSIDE
LOOKING IN THAT IT'S AN OBVIOUS
THAT THERE WOULD BE A DEMAND.
I KNOW THEY HAVE A LONG WAY LESS
BUT I WOULD JUST HOPE THAT.
SOME THOUGHT GO INTO AND AND
COLLABORATION DISCUSSION WITH
PEOPLE IN THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION PROVISION BUSINESS.
TO REALLY FIGURE OUT WHAT KIND
OF CARE WOULD BE.
GREATEST UTILIZED BY LEGISLATIVE
EMPLOYEES.
YOU KNOW INFANT CARE S. IS
ACROSS THE STATE MORE DIFFICULT
TO FIND.
IF IT'S.
SICK CHILD CARE GIVEN THE
NATURE OF OUR WORK IF THAT IS
IS.
.
IT IN GREATER DEMAND I JUST
THINK IF WE'RE GONNA INCLUDE THE
CONSTRUCTION IT SHOULD BE
THOUGHTFUL AND STRATEGIC AND
REALLY APPLY TO THE ACTUAL NEED.
OF STAFF AS OPPOSED TO.
THE BUSINESS PLAN YOU WOULD
ENGAGE IN TO JUST BUILD A CHILD
CARE FACILITY THAT NEEDS GENERAL
LICENSING STANDARDS SO MANY
IMPRINT ROOMS AT FEDEX THAT ARE.
THE W. THIS OPPORTUNITY TO.
CREATE A DESIGN AND THE
PROVISION OF THE KIND OF CARE ON
THAT THE LEGISLATIVE STAFF
ACTUALLY NEED.
IT'S VERY COSTLY LA AND AND I
KNOW THAT.
.
BASED ON THE COSTS.
CHARGED BY PREVIOUS VENDORS
SOMETIMES IT'S BEEN COST
PROHIBITIVE BASED ON SALARY
LEVELS OF PAVE HERE AT THE
BUILDINGS THAT WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT THAT TOO. I'M CURIOUS IF
ANY OF THE OTHER PROJECTS YOU'VE
BEEN INVOLVED IN HAVE INCLUDED
CHILDCARE FACILITIES AND WHAT
YOUR STRATEGY WAS IN.
IN BUILDING IT EXPANDED UPON
THEM.
YEAH IT'S AN INTERESTING
SUBJECT AND I I THINK.
MOST OF THE SUBJECTS ASSOCIATED
WITH DOING A DESIGNED FOR THIS
BUILDING WOULD INCLUDE.
A VERY DELIVERED A VERY
THOUGHTFUL PROCESS FOR EVERY
ASPECT OF INCLUDING JUST EVEN
HEARING ROOMS AND MEETING SPACES
SO.
EACH ONE OF THEM HAS A CERTAIN
LEVEL OF I GUESS ON AN EMOTIONAL
AND A.
.
I I GUESS A CAREFUL THOUGHT THAT
NEEDS TO GO ONTO I'M I THINK.
CHILD CARE WE HAVE TALKED.
WHEN WE WERE WORKING IN WYOMING
WE TALK THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
THAT IS THEY HAVE THE SAME
SIMILAR PROBLEM THEY HAVE A LOT
OF PEOPLE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE THEIR CHILD CARE. LOCALLY
CONVENIENT. GENERALLY SPEAKING
THESE TYPES OF BUILDINGS ARE NOT
CONDUCIVE CONDUCIVE TO.
.
CHILD CARE AND SO I I GUESS I
WOULD.
SUGGEST THAT IF IT WAS GOING TO.
.
THE PART OF THE PROJECT FIRST
AND WE LOOK AT IS IS THERE A.
LOCAL ADJACENT THAT IS EASIER
BECAUSE.
CHILD CARE HAS VERY SPECIFIC
RULES ARE DIFFERENT THAN ON
OFFICE BUILDING AND SO THOSE ARE
SOME CONSIDERATIONS.
IT DOESN'T MEAN IT CAN'T BE DONE
WITHIN THE BUILDING NOW.
AND SO AND IT'S IT.
I I BELIEVE THERE'S ACTUALLY
NUMBERS IN THERE RIGHT NOW FOR
SOME OF THAT.
WE HAVE NOT.
THE LIBERTY WE HAVE RIGHT NOW AS
WE GET TELL YOU GUYS THIS IS
WHAT YOUR OPTIONS ARE. AND YOU
GET TO TELL US IN THE FUTURE HOW
YOU'D LIKE TO USE THOSE OPTIONS
AND I I BELIEVE THAT IT'S. IT IT
PERFECTLY COULD FIT WITHIN WHAT
WE ARE.
TALKING ABOUT AS FAR SQUARE
FOOTAGE AND THE.
THE THOUGHT PROCESS FOR IT IT
MEANS THAT YOU WOULD PROBABLY
NEED TO BE ON THE FIRST FLOOR.
OR IT COULD BE HIGHER BUT
GENERALLY SPEAKING THOSE SPACES
WHO ARE NEED TO BE ADJACENT TO
THE EXTERIOR EXITING SYSTEMS.
AND BECAUSE IT'S A LOT HARDER
TO.
GET A WHOLE BUNCH OF YOUNG
PEOPLE OUT OF THE BUILDING BIG
REASONS INCLUDED. THAN IT IS TO
GET ADULTS ON THE BILLING SO
USUALLY WHAT GOES ON A LOCAL.
I KNOW FIRST FOUR KIND OF EXIT
STRUCTURE SO I I THINK IT COULD
EASILY ADDED AND AND I THINK
THAT ALL OF THE SPACES AND ALL
THE CONVERSATION WE JUST HAD.
FOR REQUIRE EVERYBODY'S.
I I I THINK ATTENTION TO MAKE
SURE WE MAKE DECISIONS THAT. ARE
OUR DECISIONS RESERVE WERE URBAN
ECHO OF.
WELL YOU GUYS WOULD DESIRE AND
SO THAT'S WHY ALL THE WAY
THROUGH OUR REPORT WE TALKED
ABOUT WHAT WE HEARD AND IT'S NOT
WHAT WE WERE GONNA. TELL YOU
HAVE TO DO WILL TELL YOU IF WE
THINK THAT YOU HAVE BETTER
OPTIONS.
OR THAT YOU'RE SUGGESTING ABOUT
OPTION WHICH.
I THINK THOSE ARE OWES OF.
ARE JOB BUT WHAT ACTUALLY GOES
ON THE BUILDING IS TRULY UP TO
YOU GUYS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND AND WITH
THAT MISTER CHAIR THAT I WOULD
SUGGEST I MEAN WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT IT IN IN.
IN TERMS OF OUR OWN EXPERIENCE
EXPERIENCE OF STAFF CREATES A
THIRD HOUSE WE TALK ABOUT THE
GENERAL PUBLIC IN TERMS OF THE
VISITING CENTER. THAT IN TERMS
OF A CHILD CARE FACILITY THAT
THERE WOULD BE AN EXTRA ELEMENT
OF DUE DILIGENCE THAT WOULD BE.
ON INCUMBENT UPON US TO ENGAGE
IN IN TERMS OF ENGAGING THE
ELSEWHERE IN THE BUSINESS OF
CONSTRUCTING AND RUNNING
CHILDCARE FACILITIES BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT A.
AS WELL AS AN ASSESSMENT OF YOU
KNOW THE THE GENERAL.
OFFERINGS IN THE AREA AND FOR
US TO LOOK BACK AT THE HISTORY
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT IS INDEED
LEGISLATIVE STAFF. WHO?
PREDOMINATELY UTILIZE THE
FACILITY IN THE LLB AS OPPOSED
OTHER STATE EMPLOYEES I THINK
THAT WE NEED TO DO SOME
HOMEWORK.
UM TO FIGURE OUT WHAT OUR
EXPERIENCE AS CHILLY BEEN THERE
AND TO FIGURE OUT WHAT MAKES
SENSE FOR LEGISLATIVE EMPLOYEES
TO MAKE AFFORDABLE SO THEY CAN
ACCESS IT.
EXCEPT US I THINK WE HAVE TO DO
THAT RELIGION.
WELL AND I THINK THAT FITS WITH
THE PROCESS YOU KNOW LAST YEAR
THE HEARING TO IS REALLY.
THE SEQUENCE APPEARANCE WAS TO.
LET US ON JOINT RULES WHO HADN'T
DEALT WITH A BUILDING IN A
GENERATION.
START BUILDING THE COMMON
FRAMEWORK OF UNDERSTANDING THE
PROCESS THE ISSUES THAT WAS
MISTER HART TALKING ABOUT. OTHER
CONSTRUCTIONS OUR OWN GENERAL
SERVICES WITH ADJACENT CANDY.
OUR STAFF DIANNE BEUERLEIN SO I
THINK THAT FITS WITH THE IDEA
OF.
HOW DO WE BUILD A COMMON
FRAMEWORK UNDERSTAND THE CHOICES
THE OPTIONS
HOW IT FITS IN SPECIALTY RULES
OF MAY APPLY? OTHER WOULD
ENFORCE A CHOICE WHAT IS
CONVENIENT.
ETCETERA.
SO I THINK THAT JUST BECOMES
ANOTHER.
ANOTHER STUDY TO SUPPORT.
OUR DELIBERATIONS.
VERY GOOD.
SO AS SENATOR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU CAN I HAVE THE FLOOR
pWELL CERTAINLY MAKE BETTER
THANK.
NOT.
COM I HAVE A TWO FOLD QUESTION
IT'S SORT OF A MARKETING
QUESTION AND IT'S A MANAGEMENT
QUESTION.
I BEEN UP HERE FOR ALMOST THREE
YEARS AND I DON'T SEE A C. E.
O..
AROUND HERE I DON'T SEE WHO'S.
YOU KNOW WHERE THE BUCK STOPS AT
THERE'S A PROJECT SO.
WHO WE DEAL OR SUFFER FROM
PROJECTS THAT DON'T DO WELL?
HIGH SPEED RAIL IS NOT POPULAR
IN MY DISTRICT PEOPLE MONNING
GROWN AND IT'S ALREADY OVER
BUDGET BY BILLIONS.
SO THAT'S RIGHT WHO DO YOU
BLAME.
AND WHO WHO GETS. YOU KNOW THEIR
EARS CHEWED OFF. SO.
.
WHEN IT COMES TO REMODELING OR
DOING SOME LIKE THIS IT'S ALWAYS
LIKE TWO TIMES WOULD. YOU LIKE
TO A BATHROOM PROJECT YOUR
KITCHEN PROJECT YOU MENTAL
DOUBLE THE TIME. AND DOUBLE THE
BID IS YOU'RE GONNA GET CHANGE
ORDERS AND YOU'RE GONNA GET COST
OVERRUNS.
AND SO I'M JUST WONDERING HOW
TWO WE. HOW DO WE INCENTIVIZE
THE PROJECT AT WHEN YOU SEE IT'S
GONNA TAKE THREE YEARS AND IT'S
GOING TO COST FIVE HUNDRED?
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS GONNA
BE A FUN MARKETING.
CONCERN TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
MANNERS HOMELESSNESS AND ALL
THESE OTHER ISSUES.
IF SO HOW DO WE HOW DO YOU MAKE
SURE YOU GET THE YOU KNOW YOU IN
THE TEAM ALL THE CONTRACTORS.
DO THE JOB ON TIME ON BUDGET.
AND IS SIR THE ABILITYFOR THE
STATE TO GIVE AN INCENTIVE TO
SAY KEEP GET EVERYTHING WERE
SUPPOSED TO HELP YOU GET OUT OF
BOYS OPPOSE IT JUST TOOK A STICK
ALL THE TIME.
BUT EVEN WITH THE STICK WERE
STUCK GRAY WE DON'T YOU KNOW IF
YOU SAY IT'S GOING TO COST.
FIFTY MILLION MORE. TEN PERCENT
OVER AND IT'S LIKE WHAT WE DO.
THOUGHT JUST WONDERING WHO WHO
AROUND HERE. IS IN CHARGE
BECAUSE WE. MADE TERM ROUTER YOU
KNOW WE'RE WORK WE'RE JUST
FLUID.
BUT I DON'T STE AYE I KNOW THAT
THAT MAKES SENSE BUT YOU'VE DONE
IT FOR COUPLE OTHER STATES.
IT'S A HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT
AT THE YUBA DAY WERE ALL HAPPY
REZAEI THANK YOU GREAT. WHO WON
A RECOMMENDED EVERYBODY ELSE?
WELL THAT WOULD BE OUR GOAL.
AS I AS I NOTED. EARLY IN MY
PRESENTATION THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN POWER TO MAKE
DECISIONS.
AND. WRANGLING TOGETHER
EVERYBODY TO MAKE A DECISION AND
AND.
.
BRING TO SOME KIND OF CONSENSUS
AND A SPECIFIC DIRECTION VERY
POOR.
PRIOR TO PROCEEDING WITH THE
PROJECT AND. UNDERSTANDING THAT
YOUR NAY SAYERS NEED TO BE
BROUGHT ALONG AND BOUGHT BROUGHT
IN TO THE PROCESS.
ARE ARE INCLUSIVE NATURE OF
HAVING OUR.
WHOLE STUDY DONE WAS TO INCLUDE
AS MANY PEOPLE AS WE COULD NOT
JUST THE PEOPLE WE KNEW THAT.
AND WE DIDN'T KNOW WHO WOULD
ACTUALLY LIKE IT OR NOT LIKE IT
BUT WE WANT EVERYBODY INVOLVED
BECAUSE WE THINK BY BEING
INCLUSIVE. YOU CAN GIVE
SOMETHING TO EVERYBODY THAT GIVE
SOME ABILITY TO BUY INTO THE
PROJECT.
DOING THAT HELPS YOU STOP THE
DECISION MAKING.
AS YOU GOING TO CONSTRUCTION
WHAT DAMAGES PROJECTS IS
DECISION MAKING AFTER THE FACT.
IF YOU CAN COME TO A
CONSOLIDATED THIS IS WHAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO DO. AND YOU CAN
PROCEED ON A FIT SCHEDULED TO
THAT. THEN THE STICK PORTION OF
IT WORKS BECAUSE YOU'VE GIVEN
THE CONTRACTOR VERY SPECIFIC
DIRECTIONS THAT DO THAT.
BUT IF YOU SAY DO THIS BUT ALSO
IT KINDA DO THIS OR KIND AND YOU
THIS WHICH IS A PROBLEM WITH ANY
HOME RENOVATION AS YOU
MENTIONED.
FIXING YOUR BATHROOM FIXING YOUR
KITCHEN.
I WOULD SAY SO YOU HAVE TO GIVE
YIELD SOME AUTHORITY TO SOMEBODY
ELSE AND SO MY WIFE IN OUR
KITCHEN.
NOT ME SO SHE MADE THOSE
DECISIONS SOMEBODY HOUSE THAT
YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE YOU AGREE
ON WHAT IS THE PATH FOR DECISION
MAKING.
AND WHAT IS THE PATH.
FOR CHANGING THOSE DECISIONS
BECAUSE AS YOU SAID.
YOU'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH AND
WHEN WE DID IDEA HOW WE WENT
THROUGH.
FOR. FOR FIVE LEGISLATIVE
BODIES
AND FIVE GOVERNOR'S.
THERE'S A LOT OF POSSIBILITY.
FOR.
PROJECT TO GO AWRY DURING ALL
THIS CHANGES WHAT I WOULD SAY IS
THAT.
YOU'VE ALREADY DONE THE RIGHT
THING YOU HAVE.
THE JOINT COMMITTEE.
THAT CAN MAKE THESE.
DECISIONS AND SET THIS UP A
PRIORITY FOR.
YOU NEED HAVE CONSISTENCY IN
THAT YOU NEED TO HAVE ONE PERSON
THAT IS EMPLOYED. FOR THE
PURPOSES WITHIN THE GOVERNMENT
AND IT COULD BE ONE OR TWO OR
THREE BUT DO YOU HAVE A HERO
THAT YOU DECIDE THIS PERSON IS
EMPLOYED AND FOR THE DURATION OF
THE PROJECT. THEY CAN REMEMBER
AND THIS IS WHY WE ARE TEAM WHO
HAS WORKED ON THREECAPITAL
PROJECTS IS THE SAME TEAM THAT
GOT TOGETHER BACK IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT.
BECAUSE CONSISTENCY OF KNOWLEDGE
KEEPS YOU ON TRACK AND IF YOU
CHANGE JOBS IF YOU MODIFY IF YOU
HAVE. ARCHITECTURAL AND
ENGINEERING STAFF THE CHANGE
THAT ARE IN LEADERSHIP POSITIONS
THEY FORGET WHY THEY'RE DOING
WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND THEY
CAN'T REMIND OTHER PEOPLE.
WHY THEY'RE DOING WHAT THEY'RE
OING AND SO?
I DON'T HAVE OF SILVER BULLET.
BUT I DO BELIEVE IF YOU STOP
MAKING.
DECISIONS AT A POINT IN YOUR
ALLOW THE DESIGN TEAM TO FINISH
WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND YOU CAN
ACCEPT THAT THAT'S A GOOD ENOUGH
SOLUTION BECAUSE THIS ISN'T YOUR
HOUSE.
PEOPLE'S HOUSE EVERYBODY GETS TO
USE IT OVER LONG PERIODS OF
TIME.
YOU YOU'RE NOT THE.
AS AS AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY AND
AS THE GOVERNOR YOU'RE YOU'RE
NOT HERE FOREVER BUT EVER THE
GOVERNMENT HAS AND SO IF WE CAN
FOCUS ON. THOSE KIND OF TARGETS
OF THAT THE GOVERNMENT IS
FOREVER.
AND WE CAN MAKE THOSE KIND OF
DECISIONS I THINK YOU CAN
ACTUALLY TASK PEOPLE WITH A VERY
SPECIFIC RESPONSIBILITIES HE
WOULD LIKE THEM TO TAKE.
SHARON AND I ARE YOU WORKING
THROUGH DG ES THAT.
ARE CURRENTLY WE'RE WORKING
THROUGH YOU GUYS JUST THROUGH
THIS COMMITTEE YEAH YEAH WELL
THE.
THE STATUTE PASSED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN PROVIDES THAT WE WILL
WORK PRETTY GS.
STATES.
PURSUANT AN AGREEMENT THE JOINT
RULES COMMITTEE SO BY STATUTE
THE ANNEX IS THE LEGISLATURE'S
BUILDING. THE GOVERNOR HAS THE
FIRST FLOOR.
IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO.
FORMULATE THE PLAN THAT WE WANT
AND INDEED YES IS OUR PARTNER.
I WOULD HAVE TO SAY A D. G. S.
HAS BEEN A VERY WILLING AND
EAGER PARTNER.
HONESTLY THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
STATUTE.
A.
WAS RATHER OPTIMISTIC SAYING
THAT THAT JOINT RULES COMMITTEE
WOULD PROVIDE DIRECTION
BECAUSE AT THAT TIME JOINT WILL
SADAT MET AND FIFTEEN OR SIXTEEN
YEARS.
SO WE HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN
WORKING.
OR THE LAST YEAR TO KIND OF.
SYSTEMATIZE A CONVERSATION WITH
IN THE LEGISLATURE.
SO THAT WE ACTUALLY BECOME A FIT
PARTNER A WITH THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH ON THIS PROJECT.
SO IT IS IT IS CONTEMPLATED
THAT.
.
WE WOULD TURN TO THEM FOR ALL
MANNER OF SUPPORT.
BECAUSE OF THEIR SPECIALLY AND
AND.
THEY'VE BEEN SUPPORTIVE EVE
EVEN THE EXTENT OF TRAVEL US TO
LOOK AT SOME OTHER CAPITALS AS
WE'RE TRYING TO LEARN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER VERY
GOOD. ARM.
WELL AT THIS POINT I JUST WANT
TO THANK YOU.
.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
PROJECT.
.
AND.
SHE HAS CHANGED YOU WAVE DONE
OUTSTANDING WORK FOR US.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION HERE TODAY.
I WANT TO REMIND ANYONE WHO'D BE
WATCHING THIS HEARING OF THOSE
IN THE AUDIENCE.
WE DO HAVE A WEBSITE.
THAT IS BEEN UP AND RUNNING
SINCE LAST YEAR.
IT'S ANNEX DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA
DOT GOV.
AND DOT ASSEMBLY GUTSY DOT GOV.
A YOU CAN GO THERE YOU'LL FIND A
GREAT DEAL OF INFORMATION ON
THIS PROJECT EIGHT INTO THE WORK
OF LAST YEAR. CURACY SPECIFIC
LINK ADDED TODAY THE AND EXPLAIN
STUDY SO THE FULL STUDY THAT
WE'VE SEEN REVIEW OF IS
AVAILABLE. ONLINE.
.
I WANT TO SAY IT'S A.
IT IS THAT SAME PROCESS AS JOINT
RULES CHAIR TO BE.
PARTICIPATED IN THEIR HOUSE.
AND I WANT TO SHARE. ITS OR HOW
YOUR LIFE WORKS OUT.
TWO WEEKS.
TWO WEEKS BEFORE I WAS EVER ON
ELECTED OFFICIALS.
BACK AND A TWO THOUSAND THREE.
A LETTER SHOWED UP ON MY AT MY
HOME.
AND WAS ONE OF THOSE LITTLE
ENVELOPES OCCULT THE EIGHT TEN
SIZE ENVELOPE.
AND THIS WAS A LETTER.
I I I AM VERY PROUD OF THIS
LETTER I KID YOU NOT.
ADDRESSED TO MR KEN COOLEY.
AND IT WAS FROM U. S. SUPREME
COURT JUSTICE
ANTHONY M. KENNEDY.
A LETTER TO MY HOME FROM JUSTICE
KENNEDY.
FROM HIS PRIVATE OFFICES IN DC.
UP I WAS ON THE THRESHOLD OF
FOUND IN THE CITY OF RANCHO
CORDOVA.
AND.
.
HE SAID SUB YOU THE LETTER WHICH
WAS DIRECTED TO THAT DATE JULY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND.
THREE BUT REALLY RELATES TO THIS
WHOLE BUILDING PROJECT TO ME.
HE SAID CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU
AND ALL OF YOUR COLLEAGUES.
FOR WORKING TO REINVIGORATE THE
PRINCIPLE.
OF PARTICIPATORY DEMOCRACY.
AND THEN HE SAID.
SELF GOVERNMENT MUST NOT BE AN
ABSTRACT IDEAL.
IT MUST BE A REALITY.
AND WE MUST BE UNCEASING.
IN OUR EFFORTS
TO MAKE IT MORE EFFECTIVE AND
RESPECTED BY OUR PEOPLE.
SO I ACTUALLY FEEL THAT THIS
CONVERSATION WE ARE HAVING HERE
IN SACRAMENTO.
ABOUT THIS AND ACTS WHICH HAS
BECOME A STRAITJACKET
WHICH DOES NOT WELCOME ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
OUR. THE TO ME I.
COMPLETELY SHARE THE CONCERN
THAT THIS BE ADMINISTERED IN A
SOUND WAY COST EFFECTIVELY.
.
BUT I ALSO FEELS LIKE.
THE JUSTIFICATIONS OF WE END UP
WITH AN AN EX WHICH IS MORE
WELCOMING ALL CALIFORNIANS WHERE
THEY HAVE A. MOBILITY ISSUE A
HEARING ISSUE OF VISUAL ISSUE
WELCOMES THEM ALL HERE.
A SAFE AND SECURE SETTING SO
THAT. PARENTS WHEN THEY SEND
THEIR FOURTH GRADERS TO THE
CAPITAL. KNOW THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO HAVE PERHAPS A LIFE CHANGING
SORT OF EXPERIENCE.
BY COMING HERE AND SORT OF
UNDERSTAND THIS CONNECTION.
BETWEEN WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
PUBLIC REALM AND THEIR LIFE AND
THEIR ABILITY TO ASPIRE TO
CHANGE IT.
THE OTHER ENVELOPE I KEEP NEXT
TO THAT ONCE WHEN I WAS EIGHT I
WROTE A LETTER TO JOHN F.
KENNEDY.
I JUST THINK I WAS A GEEKY
LITTLE KID PERSONAL UNDER THE
PRESENT I STATES.
BUT TO THINK SOMEHOW YOU KNOW
YOU COULD EVEN AT THAT STAGE
MAKE A CONNECTION.
AND UNDERSTAND THAT THIS COULD
BE A PART OF MY LIFE.
I FEEL THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IN
REPRESENTS.
SO ARE I DO WANT TO PLUG THAT
WEBSITE BECAUSE OUR VERY FIRST
HEARING.
WE HEARD FROM THE PROJECT
MANAGER THAT'S DONE MANY STATE
CAPITALS.
AND A CLEAR MESSAGE.
WAS THAT WHILE THIS WILL SEEM.
NOT SUB IN THE MOST OF US HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED IN AS YOU BEEN
INVOLVED A JOHN WAYNE AIRPORT
ACTUALLY. OUTSTANDING EXPERIENCE
NOT TYPICAL FOR ALL OF US.
STILL THE PROFESSIONALS TO WORK
IN THIS SPACE
SAY YOU KNOW. A LOT OF STATES
ARE DOING THIS YOU CAN DO IT YOU
HAVE OUTSIDE RESOURCES HERE.
AND SO I JUST THINK WE NEED TO.
YOU KNOW CALM OUR FEARS PROCEED
WITH GREAT DILIGENCE.
AND A SYMBOL A STRONG TEAM
AND JUST MOVE FORWARD A PUBLIC
VISION OF WHAT THE BUILDING
COULD BE BUT SO WHAT THAT I
WOULD JUST A BUT MR VICE CHAIR I
THINK YOU'RE.
GOOD.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY.
.
THANK YOU US MORE LIKE SAVE ME
AGAIN PUBLIC COMMENT.
THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS
REPUBLIC COMET ANYONE WISHING TO
MAKE.
OFFER OBSERVATIONS TODAY.
THE LAPEL PIN IS A BUNDLE OF
STICKS.
AND.
WE SAW THAT SLIDE OF THE DOOR
WHICH HAD THE BEARS HAD ON A BUT
ON THAT SAID A DOORS ON THE
SECOND FLOOR. YOU'D FIND A
BUNDLE OF STICKS IT ISN'T ALL
THE MONEY MIL STAIRCASES
THROUGHOUT THIS BUILDING.
SO IT IS PROMINENT IN THE
STAIRCASES WHENEVER PEOPLE WOULD
WALK UP AND DOWN. THE BUNDLE OF
STICKS STANDS FOR OUR SYSTEM OF
DEMOCRACY.
ARE MISTER MORLOCKS INDIVIDUAL
MISTER CANALES INDIVIDUAL I AM
INDIVIDUAL.
SENATOR MITCHELL LEYVA.
MONEY AND WE'RE ALL INDIVIDUALS
BOY TAKE THAT OATH OF OFFICE
WHICH BINDS US TOGETHER IS
STRONG AND FLEXIBLE. GOES ALL
THE WAY BACK TO ANCIENT ROME
WHEN MORE ROMAN MATCH WHICH
OCCUR IN THE BUNDLE STICKS.
AS OF SOME OTHER OFFICE IT'S
ALSO CAST IN THE ART OF EVERY
EVERY OLD LAMP IN CAPITAL PARK.
IT IN CIRCLES THE LAMP SO WHAT
IS THE MOST PROMINENT SYMBOL
THAT EARLY CALIFORNIA'S GAPS.
LEFT US OF OUR SISTER GOVERNMENT
IN THE LAMPS IN THE STAIRCASES
IN THE ORIGINAL SECOND FOUR
DOORS.
AND ON THIS BOOK.
SWITZER ARE FRAIL.
BUT STRONG DEMOCRACY. SO HAVING
NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT I
THINK YOU ALL FOR ATTENDING. AND
TO INVITE YOU AGAIN TO EXPLORE
THE WEBSITE SEE THE WORK THAT'S
BEEN DONE AND THE FULL REPORT AS
PUBLIC AS OF TODAY ON THAT
WEBSITE. AND THIS BEEN IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU VERY MUCH